Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行在Airbnb上预订会更好。现在，你可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大及其许多当地隐藏的瑰宝。我曾在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。第一年，剧组给我安排了住处。第二年，我就想，嘿，不管那笔制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能给我，让我自己去更像社区的地方找个住处，你知道吗？是的。我确实这么做了，我租了一间Airbnb，一个小公寓，正对着公园，非常可爱。我喜欢那位房东，我在那里住了两个月。哇。是的，而且我离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的觉得我在那里过上了一种小生活。我在想加拿大落基山脉地区，那里有湖泊和阿尔伯塔省的落基山脉。我不知道，感觉如果你在那里给自己找个舒适的小木屋。你知道我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园。
Well, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. When does fast delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without its grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit, but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner.
好吧，听着，也许你应该考虑为你的下一次冒险选择Airbnb。我是说，我们很喜欢它。非常喜欢。通过Instacart进行快速配送在什么时候最重要？当你的招牌芥末籽土豆沙拉没有了芥末籽就不再出名的时候。当烧烤架点着了，却没什么可烤的时候。当公婆突然决定，其实他们要留下来吃晚饭的时候。
Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus, enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello, and welcome to your second drink of the convention. Ain't no party like a Scranton party. A Scranton party, don't stop.
Instacart今夏为你包办了所有杂货。所以下载应用程序，最快60分钟内送达。此外，前三单还可享受0美元配送费。服务费、排除条款和条件适用。Instacart，超额交付的杂货服务。你好，欢迎来到大会的第二杯酒。没有派对能像斯克兰顿派对那样。斯克兰顿派对，永不停歇。
That's right. So I went back to our mailbag for the convention. Ain't no party like a Scranton party. Cause Scranton party don't stop. That's right. So I went back to our mail bag for the convention. I looked at comments and mail that we got for after our breakdown came out, just to see if there was anything that people felt like we missed. I'm proud to say there was not much.
没错。所以我回到了我们大会的邮件袋。没有派对能像斯克兰顿派对那样。因为斯克兰顿派对永不停歇。没错。所以我回到了我们大会的邮件袋。我看了我们在解析发布后收到的评论和邮件，只是想看看有没有什么大家觉得我们遗漏的地方。我很自豪地说，没漏掉多少。
But there was one very big fan mail flurry. Oh yes. And I tried to grab everyone who wrote in about this. So here we go. Hannah B, Alexis L, Alicia W, Lisa S, Carly D, Susanna W, Jenna D, Taylor R, Nikki W, Jennifer P, Andrew L, Miley W, Hailey L, Ali S, Bailey M, Emily W, and Erin P.
但确实有一大波粉丝来信。哦，是的。我试着抓取了所有写信提到这件事的人。所以我们开始吧。Hannah B, Alexis L, Alicia W, Lisa S, Carly D, Susanna W, Jenna D, Taylor R, Nikki W, Jennifer P, Andrew L, Miley W, Hailey L, Ali S, Bailey M, Emily W, 和 Erin P。
Well, that's a lot of people, lady. Why don't you tell everyone what they caught? It was a continuity catch. Here's what all those people wrote in to say, that in season five, episode three, Business Ethics, Meredith admits to having sex in exchange for supplies and Outback Steakhouse gift certificates. Right.
哇，那可是很多人啊，女士。你为什么不告诉大家他们发现了什么？这是一个关于连续性的发现。这就是所有这些人写信来说的内容：在第五季第三集《商业道德》中，梅雷迪思承认为了换取办公用品和Outback牛排馆的礼品卡而发生性关系。没错。
And she is having sex with the Scranton Hammer Mill rep for like six years. That's what she says. Oh. However, Hammer Mill was exclusive to Staples until this episode of the convention, which is season three, episode two. So by the time we get to Meredith's storyline in season five, Hammer Mill would have only been with us for two years.
而且她和斯克兰顿Hammer Mill的代表发生了大约六年的性关系。她是这么说的。哦。然而，Hammer Mill在这一集大会之前是Staples的独家供应商，也就是第三季第二集。所以当我们看到第五季梅雷迪思的故事线时，Hammer Mill和我们合作才不过两年。
It's a lot of math. And you might think, okay, what happened here? Mm-hmm. I like to think that Meredith was having sex with the Hammer Mill rep, and that she didn't even know that they didn't supply us with paper until this episode. I don't know why. I don't know why I feel like that could track.
这数学算起来很复杂。你可能会想，好吧，这里发生了什么？嗯。我倾向于认为梅雷迪思一直在和Hammer Mill的代表发生性关系，而且她甚至不知道直到这一集他们才给我们供应纸张。我不知道为什么。我不知道为什么我觉得这说得通。
I feel like that could track. I feel like she's probably not really keeping up with where everyone's working. If you say you supply paper to Dunder Mifflin, Meredith will show you a good time. Pretty much. There it is. Well, we also got several letters similar to this one
我觉得这说得通。我觉得她可能根本没留意每个人都在哪里工作。如果你说你给邓德·米夫林供应纸张，梅雷迪思就会让你玩得开心。差不多就是这样。就是这样。好吧，我们还收到了几封类似的信，
from Meadow S. Okay, in the scene where Michael and Dwight are discussing what possible fluids the black light could be revealing in the hotel room, gross, Meadow says, I am curious if that was a real hotel room and those fluids were really there, or did you guys concoct fluids that would show up? If so, what was used? I asked this out of a morbid fascination because I
来自Meadow S。好的，在迈克尔和德怀特讨论黑光灯在酒店房间里可能揭示出什么液体的那一幕，真恶心，Meadow说，我很好奇那是不是一个真实的酒店房间，那些液体真的在那里，还是你们编造了会显现出来的液体？如果是的话，用了什么？我问这个问题是出于一种病态的好奇心，因为我
fear the fluids in hotel rooms, so much so that we VRBO whenever possible. Assuming and hoping they clean better and wash all the bedding, etc. Thank you so much. Love your show and podcast. Okay. Well- There's no way those fluids were real. No. No. Please tell me no. Yeah. The answer is no. Okay, well, there's no way those fluids were real. No, no. Please tell me no. Yeah. The answer is no. Okay. I reached out to our production designer, Michael Gallenberg. Oh my gosh, poor Michael. What are you texting me about? What did you
害怕酒店房间里的液体，以至于我们尽可能选择VRBO。假设并希望他们打扫得更干净，洗过所有的床上用品等等。非常感谢。喜欢你们的节目和播客。好的。好吧——那些液体不可能是真的。不。不。请告诉我不是。是的，答案是不。好的，好吧，那些液体不可能是真的。不，不。请告诉我不是。是的，答案是不。好的。我联系了我们的美术指导，迈克尔·加伦伯格。哦天哪，可怜的迈克尔。你给我发短信问什么？你在墙上喷了什么？
spray on the walls? And he said that he had to reach out to the person he called his quote unquote paint lord. Oh. Who is Ron Henson. The paint lord? Yes. I guess he was in charge of all of our paint for our productions. He got the tech specs for what Ron used on the walls. Michael, thank you so much for going to this length
他说他不得不联系他称之为“油漆之王”的人。哦。也就是罗恩·亨森。“油漆之王”？是的。我想他负责我们制作中所有的油漆。他拿到了罗恩在墙上使用的技术规格。迈克尔，非常感谢你为我们和我们的听众做到这一步。
for us and our listeners. Here's what it was. It was a product called Wildfire. And evidently, it is only available through film industry vendors, at least at the time. And it is a liquid reactive medium vehicle that responds to black light, but is invisible to the eye in normal light.
这就是它。它是一种叫做Wildfire的产品。显然，它只通过电影行业供应商提供，至少在当时是这样。它是一种液体反应介质载体，对黑光有反应，但在正常光线下肉眼不可见。
Basically, it's just a really high-end black light paint. Okay. And that is what we splattered all over. All over the place. And then he sent me a photo of his view in Florida and it is gorgeous. I know he moved there. Yeah, I mean, stunning.
基本上，它就是一种非常高端的黑光漆。好的。这就是我们到处喷洒的东西。到处都是。然后他给我发了一张他在佛罗里达的风景照，非常漂亮。我知道他搬到那里去了。是的，我是说，太惊艳了。
He loves it. I see why. Will you show me the picture? Yes, look at that. Oh my gosh, that's lovely. He loves it. I see why. Will you show me the picture? Yes, look at that. Oh my gosh, that's lovely. Right? Yeah. Thank you, Michael Gallenberg.
他很喜欢那里。我明白为什么。你能给我看那张照片吗？是的，看那个。哦天哪，太可爱了。他很喜欢那里。我明白为什么。你能给我看那张照片吗？是的，看那个。哦天哪，太可爱了。对吧？是的。谢谢你，迈克尔·加伦伯格。
You know, we also got a fan mail correction from Michael H. who said, in this breakdown, you said the Blackberry was made by RAM, but it's actually RIM, which stands for Research in Motion. They are a Canadian company out of Waterloo, Ontario. I'm not affiliated with them, but I am a proud Canadian. So given some love to Canada there. Was I the one that got it wrong?
你知道，我们还收到了迈克尔·H的粉丝邮件更正，他说，在这次解析中，你说黑莓手机是RAM制造的，但实际上是RIM，代表Research in Motion。他们是一家位于安大略省滑铁卢的加拿大公司。我与他们没有关联，但我是一个自豪的加拿大人。所以给加拿大一点爱。是我弄错了吗？
No, it was me. Oh, okay. Yeah, don't worry. Finally, we got a callback catch from Chris S. in Toronto. Chris says, I've been waiting for the convention for so long, ha ha, but may have missed the boat. My fan catch is, Angela, you got such a kick out of Pam storming off and leaving her food in season one, which I also loved as an observation.
不，是我。哦，好吧。是的，别担心。最后，我们收到了来自多伦多Chris S的反馈。Chris说，我等大会这一集等了太久了，哈哈，但可能错过了重点。我的粉丝发现是，安吉拉，你对帕姆在第一季中气冲冲地离开并留下食物感到非常兴奋，这也是我非常喜欢的一个观察。
But it immediately made me think of the convention when you storm off after Meredith says, ugh, that town smells like cheesesteak, leaving behind what looks like a bowl of cereal, which Creed promptly begins to eat. It's just a small catch, but I've been waiting since season one to write in about it.
但这立刻让我想到了大会那一集，当梅雷迪思说“呃，那个镇闻起来像芝士牛排”后，你气冲冲地离开，留下了一碗看起来像麦片的东西，克里德立刻开始吃了起来。这只是一个小发现，但我从第一季开始就一直等着写信提这件事。
All right, Angela, I saw this piece of mail as well, and it made me want to ask you, in the same way that you have made me re-examine my strong position about Jim and Pam's first kiss. Okay. Have you reconsidered your judgment of Pam for storming off and leaving part of her meal on the table?
好了，安吉拉，我也看到了这封邮件，它让我想问你，就像你让我重新审视我对吉姆和帕姆初吻的坚定立场一样。好的。你有没有重新考虑你对帕姆气冲冲地离开并把部分餐点留在桌上的评价？
Here, now your character does it in this episode. You said you would never in your life leave a half-eaten meal behind if you were in an argument. You would at least pick up your things and take them with you. Well, wait, are you asking me the person or Angela Martin the character? I think I'm asking you the person
现在你的角色在这一集中也做了同样的事。你说过如果你在争吵中，你这辈子绝不会留下一顿没吃完的饭。你至少会收拾好你的东西带走。好吧，等等，你是在问我本人还是安吉拉·马丁这个角色？我想我是在问你本人，
because you the person judged Pam. I'm sorry, I still think I would grab my spoon and go. Very tidy, even an argument. Why would I leave my food? It's my food, I might not like the company I'm in, but I'm gonna take my food with me. This was the same argument you made the first time. And I mean, it's not unreasonable.
因为你本人评判了帕姆。抱歉，我还是觉得我会拿上我的勺子离开。非常整洁，即使在争吵中。我为什么要留下我的食物？那是我的食物，我可能不喜欢和我在一起的人，但我会把我的食物带走。这和你第一次提出的论点是一样的。我是说，这并非不合理。
It's not unreasonable. Yeah, I don't know. Just because someone's pissing me off doesn't mean they get to have my food. I'm taking it. I'm going to eat it. All right. Well, thank you, everyone, for writing in.
这并非不合理。是的，我不知道。仅仅因为有人惹我生气并不意味着他们可以吃我的食物。我会拿走它。我会去吃掉它。好吧，谢谢大家的来信。
I hope we cleared up a few things. And now here is the convention. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes
希望我们澄清了一些事情。现在是大会这一集。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好，我是安吉拉·金赛。我是珍娜，今天我们要谈论的是大会。这是第三季第二集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，肯·惠廷汉姆执导。珍娜，这一集对我来说真的很有趣。我得去旅行。我得去出差。我知道，记得上周我们一直在谈论我们是如何获得第三季的大幅提升，这样我们就可以离开办公室去做事情了吗？
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Howdy everybody, Angela Kinsey here. It's Jenna and today we're talking about the convention. It's season three episode two written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stepnitsky and directed by Ken Whittingham. Jenna this was a really fun episode for me. I got to travel. I got to go on the road. I know remember last week we were talking all about how we got that big season three bump so we could leave the office and do things?
你好，我们在第二集中创造了一个完整的纸张大会。这一季我们要大干一场。好吧，让我们进入这一集。我为你准备了一个摘要。我太兴奋了。我们开始吧。做吧。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢，宝贝。宝贝，读给我听
Hello, we created an entire paper convention in episode two. We are going for it this season. All right. Well, let's get into this episode. I have a summary for you. I'm so excited. Here we go. Do it. Thanks. Thanks. Thanks, babe. Babe, read me
你的摘要，宝贝。甜心，我们开始吧。洋娃娃脸。读摘要，洋娃娃脸。嘿，宝贝。我为你准备了一个摘要。甜心脸。读摘要，甜心脸。你知道吗？我可能刚刚看了百老汇高清版的《第42街》。哦，顺便说一下，我们看了那个。李和我，我们真的很怀念现场戏剧。我们真的很怀念它。这是我们的爱好之一。他们在百老汇高清频道上有一个很棒的百老汇演出目录。
your summary, babe. Sweetie, here we go. Dollface. Read the summary, dollface. Hey, toots. I got a summary for you. Sweet cheeks. Read the summary, sweet cheeks. You know what? I might have just watched the Broadway HD 42nd Street. Oh, by the way, we watched that. Lee and I, we really miss Life Theater. We really miss it. It's one of our loves. And they have this great catalog of Broadway shows on Broadway HD.
所以我们看了《第42街》。太棒了。扮演主角的那个女人，她的名字叫克拉拉。天哪，她简直令人震撼。这个女人跳的踢踏舞简直太疯狂了。总之，但那部戏里有很多像“宝贝”、“亲爱的”、“甜心”之类的称呼。因为你知道，它设定在那个时代。
And so we watched 42nd Street. It's so good. The woman who plays the lead, her name is Clara. And oh my God, she is mind blowing. The tap dancing this woman does is just insane. So anyway, but that show has a lot of like toots, darlin', babe, honey. Cause you know, it's all set back in the time.
我不知道那是什么时候。那是什么时候？咆哮的二十年代？那是什么时候？可能是咆哮的二十年代吧。是的。好吧，总之。摘要。摘要。听着，你在电视上看你的百老汇演出吧。我要去看我的蜂鸟了。是的，这就是我们要做的。这就是我们要做的。也许我会打开天气频道。我不知道。什么都可能发生。好的。好的。迈克尔和德怀特前往费城去见简、吉姆和乔什，参加东北部中型办公用品大会。
And I don't know what time that was. What was that? The roaring twenties? When is that time? Roaring twenties, probably. Yeah. All right. Anyway, summary. Summary. Listen, you watch your Broadway shows on the telly. I'm going to watch my hummingbirds. Yeah, this is what we're doing. This is what we're doing. Maybe I'll put on the weather channel. I don't know. Anything could happen. Okay. Okay. Michael and Dwight traveled to Philadelphia to meet Jan, Jim and Josh for the Northeastern Mid-Market Office Supply Convention.
与此同时，在邓德·米夫林，凯莉安排帕姆和她的邻居艾伦约会。他是个漫画家。他们会有很多共同点。没错。但安吉拉偷偷溜走去给德怀特一个惊喜。是的。好吧，第一个快速事实，我们有一位大牌客串明星，罗伯特·巴格内尔，他扮演了漫画家艾伦。现在你可能认出他，因为他还扮演了HBO《归来记》中的汤姆·彼得曼，该剧由丽莎·库卓主演。你看过那个节目吗？我看过。我觉得她太搞笑了。好吧，整个演员阵容都很出色。我迷上了那个节目。就像着迷一样。是的，它是对娱乐业和女演员生活如此惊人的讽刺。是的。就像有一个场景，她打开冰箱，里面除了苏打水和这些预包装的减肥餐之外什么都没有，这让我笑得太厉害了。她太自恋了，而且她演得太完美了。去看看吧，伙计们，
Meanwhile, back in Dunder Mifflin, Kelly sets up Pam on a date with her neighbor Alan. He's a cartoonist. They're going to have so much in common. Right. But Angela sneaks off to surprise Dwight. Yeah. All right. Fast fact number one, we've got a big guest star, Robert Bagnell, who played Alan the cartoonist. Now you might recognize him because he also played Tom Peterman on HBO's The Comeback starring Lisa Kudrow. Did you watch that show? I did. I thought she was so funny. Well, the whole cast was phenomenal. I was obsessed with that show. Like obsessed. Yeah, it is such an amazing satire of the entertainment industry of an actress. Yes. Like there's a scene where she opens up a refrigerator and there's nothing in there except for like seltzer water and these pre-packaged diet meals and it made me laugh so hard. She's so self-obsessed and narcissistic and she plays it perfectly. Check it out guys,
太棒了。罗伯特·巴格内尔也在里面。所以我很兴奋能和他一起工作，但我认识他。怎么认识的？我们过去常一起做这种叫“即兴电影”的事情，他们会找来编剧、导演、演员和剧组人员，给你48小时拍一部短片。你们是随机匹配的。周六早上7点左右开始，拿着为你写好的小剧本。
it's amazing. And Robert Bagnell is on there. So I was so excited to get to work with him but I knew him. How? We used to do this thing called instant films together where they take these writers, directors, actors, and crew, and you get 48 hours to make a short film. You're randomly matched. You start at like 7 a.m. on Saturday with a little script that's been written for you.
通常大约四页长。周日晚上，大家聚在一起，有一个小电影节，非常有趣。是的，我有朋友做过这个，我不知道为什么我没参加，但我有朋友做过这个，而且很喜欢。好吧，这很有趣，安吉，因为你总是谈论
It's usually like four pages long. And on Sunday night, everyone gets together and there's a little film festival and it's so fun. Yeah, I have friends that did this and I don't know why I didn't participate, but I have friends that did this and loved it. Well, it's funny, Angie, because you're always kind of talking about
你是怎么做Groundlings的，或者你做过这些小品秀、即兴奥林匹克。即兴艺术节，是的。是的，我没做过那些，但我做过这些。比如短片？短片电影节，然后他们也为戏剧做了一个。
how you did the groundlings or you did these sketch shows, improv-olympic. Improv festivals, yeah. Yeah, I didn't do any of that stuff, but I did do these. Like short films? Short film festivals, and then they do one for plays as well.
他们做过那种24小时戏剧，你必须在24小时内排演一部迷你剧。所以我做过那种事情。但我就是从那里认识他的。这就是我认识罗伯特的方式。他和我一起在即兴电影的世界里。哦哇，太酷了。所以我联系了他，我们关于他在节目中的时光进行了最好的交谈，然后他给我发了两页的回忆。停下！是的！太棒了！
They do like a 24-hour play where you have to stage a mini play in 24 hours. So I would do like that kind of stuff. But I knew him from that. That's how I knew Robert. He was in the instant film world with me. Oh wow, that's so cool. So I reached out to him and we had the best conversation about his time on the show and then he sent me like two pages of memories. Stop it! Yes! That's so fantastic!
太善良，太慷慨了。所以他告诉我，他得到这个角色的方式是通过迈克·舒尔。太慷慨了。所以他告诉我，他得到这个角色的方式是通过迈克·舒尔。怎么得到的？迈克·舒尔是《归来记》第一季的编剧。哦。他实际上离开了《归来记》去《办公室》工作。我从来不知道这一点。我也不知道。天哪。我绝对会和他谈谈那个。太酷了。我知道。我怎么就不知道去追问迈克·舒尔关于丽莎·库卓的趣事呢，拜托。但关于他最疯狂的事情是这个。你想听这个疯狂的个人联系吗？好的。你和他在大学里约会吗？
So kind, so generous. So he told me that the way he got the role on the show was through Mike Schur. so generous. So he told me that the way he got the role on the show was through Mike Schur. How? Mike Schur had been a writer on season one of The Comeback. Oh. And he had actually left The Comeback to go work on The Office. I never knew that. Me either. Oh my God. I would totally have talked to him about that. That is so cool. I know. How did I not know to pepper Mike sure about questions. I Lisa could wrote tidbits please. But here is the craziest thing about him. Do you want to hear this crazy personal connection? Okay. Are you and him dating in
不，开玩笑的。说吧。不，不。但在他客串《办公室》的大约同一时间。是的，他还在我现在的丈夫李·柯克编剧的一部电影中扮演了一个角色，但我们不知道，停下！是的，他出演了这部电影叫《裤子着火》，由科林·坎贝尔执导，我丈夫李编剧。由我丈夫李编剧。所以就像他在《办公室》里和我演对手戏，然后他正在拍摄李电影里的这个角色。而李和我当时还没相爱。
college? No, I'm kidding. Go. No, no. But around the same time that he was guest starring on the office. Yeah, also had a role in a movie written by my now husband Lee Kirk, but we didn't know stop it. Yes, he was in this movie called pants on fire that was directed by Colin Campbell written by my husband Lee. written by my husband Lee. And so it was like he was doing this scene with me on the office and then he was shooting this role in Lee's movie. And Lee and I weren't in love.
你们甚至不是一回事，或者在彼此的雷达上。这太疯狂了。我知道，世界真小。这太疯狂了。那，是的，那些对我来说是小小的思维融合时刻，你们的生活在交叉，而你们甚至不知道。
You're not even a thing or knew each other on each other's radars. That is crazy. I know, such a small world. That is so crazy. That, yeah, those are the little mind melt moments for me where your lives are crisscrossing and you don't even know it.
所以你和李的生活在交叉，这太狂野了。我喜欢这个。好吧，疯狂的是，那部电影《裤子着火》，那个剧本是作为李的写作样本寄给我的。我当时要制作一部。我需要一个编剧。我拿到了《裤子着火》作为写作样本，我爱上了它。我和李开了一个会。哦，然后他最终为我写了一部电影
So you and Lee had this existence crisscrossing and that's so wild. I love that. Well, the crazy thing is, is that movie, Pants on Fire, that script was sent to me as a writing sample of Lee's. I was gonna produce a. And I needed a writer. And I got pants on fire as the writing sample and I fell in love with it. And I took a meeting with Lee. Oh, and then he ended up writing a film for me
叫《巨人机械人》。这就是李和我相爱的方式。这就是我们在《巨人机械人》上合作的，李后来执导了那部电影。哇，罗伯特也演了那部电影。罗伯特演了《裤子着火》。这不疯狂吗？哇，这太疯狂了。我喜欢这个。好吧，总之，我从罗伯特那里得到了大量有趣的信息，我会把它们穿插在
called The Giant Mechanical Man. And that is how Lee and I fell in love. That's what that we worked together on Giant Mechanical Man, which Lee then directed. Wow, and Robert was in that movie. Robert was in Pants on Fire. Isn't that crazy? Wow, that is so crazy. I love that. Alright, so anyway, I have a ton of fun information from Robert and I will sprinkle that in as
我们讲到那些场景的时候。好的，那么接下来是什么？接下来是什么？接下来是什么？女士，你的快速事实接下来是什么？接下来，快速事实二，萨姆，能给我一个粉丝问题吗？什么？粉丝问题？这是粉丝问题，安吉拉。
we get to those scenes. Okay, so what's up? What's up? what's up? What's next lady with your fast facts? Next, fast fact number two, Sam, could I get a fan question? What? Fan question? It's a fan question, Angela.
快速事实二是一个粉丝问题。我得让我的孩子们录一些东西，然后我得把它发给萨姆，下周我会穿插一个。那是我的女儿。太可爱了。好吧，你知道，因为我的儿子上周做了深度挖掘，所以。哦，那很好。那很好。她给了我一个粉丝问题提示，因为快速事实二全是粉丝问题，从瑞安·阿普加开始，全是粉丝问题。阿普加，大会在哪里
Fast fact two is a fan question. I have got to get my kids recording some stuff and then I've got to send it over to Sam and I'm gonna sprinkle one in next week. That was my daughter. That's so cute. Well you know because my son got to do the deep dive last week so. Oh that's good. That's good. She gave me a fan question sting because Fast Fact number two is all fan questions starting with Ryan Apgar, you is all fan questions. Apgar, where was the conve
伯曼，是实际的吗？必须完全租下整个酒店，并在大会上安排供应商。关于那个有太多问题了。是的，所以你知道，我去了肯托百科。肯托百科。我知道其中一两个，但肯会提供完整的内幕，所以让我们听听吧。好吧，肯告诉我，我们是在伯班克希尔顿酒店拍摄的。
Berman, was it an actual have to completely rent o the entire hotel and sar the vendors at the conven So many questions about t Yeah, so you know, I went to Kentopedia. Kentopedia. I know one or two of these, but Kent will have the full low down, so let's hear it. Alright, so Kent told me that we filmed this at the Burbank Hilton Hotel.
嗯。现在是另一家酒店了。它不再叫伯班克希尔顿了。没错，但它靠近……如果记忆没出错的话，它就在伯班克机场附近。是的。是的。他说他们没有预订整个酒店，但他们预订了酒店里最大的会议室，而且他们必须预订那个房间整整一周，因为光是把它布置得像个大会就需要整整两天。所以他说他们周一开始用所有的展位和所有东西填满它。
Mm-hmm. Which is now a different hotel. It's not called the Burbank Hilton anymore. Right, but it's near... if memory serves, it's kind of over called the Burbank Hilton anymore. Right, but it's near, if memory serves as kind of over by the Burbank airport. Yes. Yeah. He said they did not book the entire hotel, but they did book the largest convention room that the hotel had and they had to book that room for the entire week because it took two full days just to set it up to look like a convention. So he said they started on Monday filling it with all the booths and all the stuff.
当我到那里时，它看起来就像一个完整的大会。真的看起来像。所以肯告诉我，他真的很依赖他的制作人员，当他写信给我时，他说请给这些人一个大声的赞美，因为他们在实现这一目标方面发挥了重要作用。安吉拉，我要告诉你一些名字，好吗？你还记得安吉·汉密尔顿和詹姆斯·凯里吗？是的，他们和肯一起工作。是的，当然，当然我记得他们。安吉是我们的联合制片人，詹姆斯·凯里是办公室经理。他说他们在这一集拍摄前几周就得到了消息，他们将不得不举办一场大会。所以他们俩联系了数百家公司和企业，询问他们是否想参加这一集。交易是这样的。交易是他们必须自带
When I got there it looked like a full-on convention. It really did. So Kent told me that he really leaned on his production staff and when he wrote me he said will you please give these guys a shout out because they were instrumental in making this happen Angela I'm gonna hit you with some names okay do you remember Angie Hamilton and James Carey yes who worked with Kent yes of course of course I remember them Angie was our co-producer James Carey was the office manager. He said they were tipped off a few weeks before this episode was set to film that they were going to have to pull off a convention. So the two of them reached out to literally hundreds of corporations and businesses and asked if they wanted to be in the episode. And here was the deal. The deal was they had to bring their own
大会材料。他们必须设置自己的展位，提供自己的员工和服装，以便在这一集中填充它们。他们被告知不能保证他们会获得出镜时间。但他们可以尝试，你知道，他们说，我们会尽量让每个人都上镜。他说他们得到了成吨的人想要参与。这个节目现在太受欢迎了，人们很高兴能参与。所以他说最后，总共有176名所谓的“临时演员”、背景表演者，其中140人是实际公司的实际员工。
convention materials. They had to set up their own they had to bring their own convention materials. They had to set up their own booths, provide their own staff and wardrobe to sort of populate them during the episode. And they were told that they could not promise that they would get screen time. But they could try, you know, they're like, we'll try to get everyone on camera. He said they got tons of people who wanted to participate. The show is now so popular, people were like delighted to participate. So all those people he said in the end, there were 176 total quote unquote extras, background performers and 140 of them were actual employees of actual companies.
这就是为什么它看起来那么真实。因为我以为，当我浏览它时，我想，这些看起来像真正的公司，他们的衬衫是配套的等等。像我觉得我们很难做到的细节，但这是因为他们是真正的公司。我觉得这是你唯一能做到这一点的方法。凯莉·贝内特，我们的服装设计师，不可能在两周内费尽心思为多家公司设计配套的服装。是的。我是说，这是电影需要几个月准备的事情
That's why it looks so real. Cause I thought that I thought when I looked through it, I was like, these look like real companies and their shirts matched and things like that. Like details that I feel like would have been so hard for us to pull off, but it's because they were actual companies. I feel like this is the only way you could have done that. There's no way that Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer, could have painstakingly designed matching wardrobes for multiple companies. Yeah. In two weeks time. I mean, this is the kind of stuff that movies have months of preparation
，你知道，在电视里你必须在几周内完成它。所以他们就是这样做的。太神奇了。你知道，詹姆斯太贴心了。我对他的记忆非常深刻，因为我不知道，我觉得我家总是有什么东西不太对劲。就像我当时想，哦，詹姆斯，我本该打印这个的。我的打印机没墨了，我们整天都在片场。所以我们不能只是跑去买打印机墨水或者跑去，你知道，无论我们需要做什么。
for, you know, and in TV you have to pull it off in just a matter of weeks. So that's how they did it. That's amazing. You know, James was so sweet. I have such fond memories of him because I don't know, I feel like there was always something that wasn't quite working at my house. Like I was like, Oh, James, I was supposed to print this out. My printer was out of ink and we were on set all day. So it's not like we could just run and buy printer ink or run and you know, whatever it was we needed to do.
我会去那里很多次，他会说，好吧，安吉拉，你需要什么？我说，你能帮我打印这个吗？因为我告诉妈妈我会寄给她，而我的打印机，他总是随时准备帮忙，他们太棒了。安吉拉，我发现了一堆我们剧组的老照片，看着它们我哭了。我只是，你知道，每个人在看节目时看到的是演员。但我们在片场看到的是所有其他看着我们的面孔。看到这些我们的音响人员、灯光师和
And I would go in there so many times and he'd be like all right Angela what what do you need and I'm like can you print this for me because I told my mom I'd mail it to her and my printer he was just always there to help and just they were amazing Angela I found a bunch of old photos of our crew and I cried looking through them. I just, you know, it's, there's the thing that everybody sees when they're watching the show, which are the actors. But what we saw on the set were all these other faces looking back at us. And to see these pictures of our sound folks and our gaffers and our
我们的灯光师，还有我们的制片助理，再次看到他们所有的脸，真是太棒了，安吉拉，太神奇了。好了，好了，我们讲到哪了，女士？快速事实三，这一集差点出现麦肯齐·克鲁克的客串，他在英国版《办公室》中扮演了最初的德怀特版本。是的，在BBC版本里。是的，是的。所以这是我在我记得是Dunderpedia上发现的一点小道消息。但我记得这个。所以如果记忆没出错的话，麦肯齐当时在城里为
our lighters and, and our PAs and to see all their faces again it was just oh my gosh Angela it was amazing all right all right where are we at lady fast fact number three this episode almost featured a cameo by Mackenzie Crook who played the original kind of Dwight Dwight version in the British office. Yeah, on the BBC version. Yeah, yeah. So this was a little nugget that I found on I believe it was Dunderpedia. But I remember this. So I believe if memory serves Mackenzie was in town doing a big press tour for
一部电影做大型新闻巡回宣传。我想那可能是其中之一。哦，天哪，安吉拉，约翰尼·德普主演的那部他扮演海盗的电影叫什么名字？哦，加勒比海盗。约翰尼·德普扮演海盗的那部电影叫什么？我不知道。他有点在加勒比海。是的。他说，你很精明。我的继子杰克太迷那些电影了，有一年万圣节，他想扮成杰克·斯派洛船长。
a movie. I think it might have been one of the. Oh, my God, Angela, what's the name of that movie that Johnny Depp is in where he plays the pirate? Oh, Pirates of the Caribbean. What's that Johnny Depp movie where he plays a pirate? I don't know. He kind of said in the Caribbean. Yeah. And he's like, he's like, you're savvy. My stepson, Jack, was so obsessed with those movies that one year for Halloween, he wanted to be Captain Jack Sparrow.
我们给他买了全套服装。然后在圣诞节那天，我们说，伙计们，你们想穿上圣诞装吗？我们给他们买了圣诞连体衣。杰克说，我能只扮成杰克·斯派洛船长吗？所以我们在圣诞树前有一张搞笑的照片，伊莎贝尔和凯特穿着圣诞连体衣。他们看起来像个精灵，你知道，杰克是完整的杰克·斯派洛。好吧，你知道，麦肯齐·克鲁克演了那些电影。是的。是的。是的。
We got him the full costume. And then on Christmas Day, we were like, guys, you want to dress up for Christmas? We bought them all like Christmas onesies. And Jack said, Can I just dress as Captain Jack Sparrow? So we have this hilarious photo in front of the Christmas tree and Isabelle and Kate are in Christmas onesies. They look like an elf, you know, Jack is full Jack Sparrow. Well, you know, Mackenzie Crook was in those movies. Yes. Yes. Yeah.
所以我相信他当时在城里做这个新闻发布会巡回。他想让他出现在大会的一个展位里，和我们的德怀特聊几句。所以两个德怀特和我在一起。那不是太棒了吗？但后来日程安排没成功。他没能来。你知道当你做新闻发布会时那是什么感觉，特别是，我是说，我不知道当你做新闻发布会时那是什么感觉，特别是。我是说，我不知道为那种规模的电影或那种规模的系列做新闻发布会是什么感觉，但他没能来。他想来。他没能来。他是最好的人。
So I believe he was in town doing this press junket tour. He wanted to have him just appear at the convention in one of the booths and have a little chat with our Dwight. So the two kind of Dwight's with me. Wouldn't that have been amazing? But then the scheduling did not work out. He couldn't come. You know what that's like when you're doing a press junket, especially, I mean, I don't know what it's like when you're doing a press junket, especially. I mean, I don't know what it's like to do a press junket for a movie that size or a series that size, but he couldn't come. He wanted to. He couldn't come. He's the nicest guy.
我见过他。他很棒。但我知道几乎，德怀特的会面几乎发生了，但没有。珍娜，我很遗憾他没来，因为我是他的粉丝。我喜欢格雷格总是试图融入BBC的演员，我们确实见过他们好几次，但这会真的很酷。珍娜，非常感谢你提供三个精彩的快速事实。也许我们应该休息一下，然后回来进入这一集。我喜欢它，女士，我喜欢它。我喜欢它，女士。我喜欢它。
I've met him. He's awesome. But I know almost almost a meeting of the Dwight's almost happened, but did not. Jenna, I am so bummed he didn't come because I'm such a fan. And I love that Greg was always trying to incorporate the BBC cast and we got to meet them several times but that would have been really cool. Jenna, thank you so much for three fantastic fast facts. Maybe we should take a break and then we'll come back and get into this episode. I like it lady, I like it. I like it, lady. I like it.
本节目由BetterHelp赞助。女士，你看到他们做的那个关于男性健康和心理健康的搞笑《周六夜现场》小品了吗？为了诱骗男性照顾自己，他们建立了一个像播客一样的医疗诊所，就像一个“兄弟”播客。哦，天哪，太搞笑了。但这也是因为它是真的。男性通常不愿意花时间去深入了解自己的心理健康。我有一个统计数据给你。美国每年有六百万男性患有抑郁症
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you see that hilarious Saturday Night Live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where, like, in order to trick men into taking care of themselves, they made a medical clinic that is like a podcast, like a Dude Bro podcast. Oh my gosh, it's so funny. But it's also because it's kinda true. Men are often reluctant to take the time to dig into their mental health. I've got a stat for you. Six million men in the US suffer from depression every year
而且通常未被诊断。所以听着，如果你是一个男人，你感到世界的重压，我们想鼓励你和某人谈谈，一个朋友，一个爱人，一个治疗师。也许你想试试BetterHelp。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以提供访问
and it's often undiagnosed. So listen, if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world, we would like to encourage you to talk to someone, a friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you wanna give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access
拥有多样化专业知识的心理健康专业人员。通过BetterHelp谈出来。我们的听众在betterhelp.com/officeladies上首次订购可享受10%的折扣。那是betterhelp，H-E-L-P，点com斜杠officeladies。嗨，我是瑞安·雷诺兹，我有一份我喜欢在片场准备的东西清单。
to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P, dot com slash office ladies. Hi there, I'm Ryan Reynolds, and I have a list of things I like to have on set.
这只是一些小东西，比如两个刚打碎的鸡蛋，配上酥脆的薯饼、香肠碎和蒂姆霍顿的奶油墨西哥辣椒酱。从我的要求到蒂姆的菜单，试试我新的炒蛋早餐盒。好了，我们回来了。帕姆在她的办公桌前，迈克尔进来说，嘿，你看奥普拉了吗？
It's just little things like two freshly cracked eggs scrambled with crispy hash browns, sausage, crumble, and creamy Chipotle sauce from Tim Hortons. From my rider to Tim's menu, try my new scrambled eggs loaded breakfast box. All right, and we are back. Pam is at her desk and Michael enters and says, hey, did you see Oprah?
因为我想成为一名父亲。你说，等等，奥普拉上有什么？迈克尔看奥普拉的最大收获是他得知安吉丽娜·朱莉领养了一个婴儿，所以现在他也想领养一个婴儿。是的。他想让帕姆参与进来。帕姆，参与进来。
Because I want to be a father. And you're like, wait what was on what was on Oprah? Michael's big takeaway from watching Oprah is that he learns that Angelina Jolie has adopted a baby so now he wants to adopt a baby. Yeah. And he wants Pam to get on it. Pam get on it.
帕姆说，我觉得你应该等等，因为罗伊的妹妹调查过，光是申请费就要一千美元，迈克尔说，你不能帮我找个便宜点的婴儿吗？然后她说，嗯，而且这需要很长时间，像八个月的周期，八个月，他说，哦天哪，我甚至不知道八个月后我还会不会想要个婴儿。史蒂夫在那里的表演真的很有趣。你的反应也很好。你对你说“奥普拉上有什么？”时的反应。我很害怕。这要去哪？这要去哪？最后，帕姆同意如果30年内他们俩都没有孩子，她就给迈克尔生个孩子。
And Pam's like I think you should wait because Roy's sister looked into it and like the application alone cost a thousand dollars and Michael's like can't you find me a cheaper baby and then she's like well also it takes a long time like eight months period it's like eight months and he's like oh my god I don't even know if I'm gonna want a baby in eight months Steve's play on that was really funny. And your reaction was so good. Your reaction to when you say, what was on Oprah? I'm scared. Where's this going? Where is this going? Well, in the end, Pam agrees that she will have Michael's baby if neither one of them have a baby in 30 years.
因为她觉得我不能，我逃不掉这个。是的。是的。但我知道这会回来困扰她的。所以30年后，当你50岁时，你会生这个孩子。我会生他的孩子。哦，天哪。当我56岁的时候。是的，基本上。好吧，就是这样。
Because she sees like I can't I'm not going to get out of this. Yeah. Yeah. But I know that's going to come back to haunt her. So in 30 years, when you're 50, you'll have this baby. I'll have his baby. Oh, my gosh. When I'm like 56. Yeah, basically. Well, there you go.
但你知道，迈克尔会到处告诉别人他和帕姆已经同意生个孩子。你们会漏掉“30年后”那部分吗？是的。不，这段对话现在会困扰她。是的，肯定的。肯定的。他会告诉别人你们是彼此的备选计划。是的。所以现在我们在实际的剧集中，迈克尔，你知道，正在打包。第一次旅行。他让瑞安帮他。
But you know, Michael's going to go around and tell people that he and Pam have agreed to have a baby. You guys going to leave out the in 30 years part? Yeah. No, this conversation is going to haunt her now. Yeah, for sure. For sure. He's going to tell people you guys are each other's backup plan. Yeah. So now we're in the actual episode and Michael, you know, is packing. First trip. He has Ryan helping him.
这是他的打包清单，对吧，为这次大会。三条裤子，三双袜子，三盒避孕套。三盒。有趣的牛仔裤，三盒。珍娜，我不该这么做，但我深入研究了一盒里有多少个避孕套。多少个，像一打？
Here's his his packing list, right, for this convention. Three pairs of pants, three pairs of socks, three packs of condoms. Three packs. Fun jeans, three packs. Jenna, I shouldn't have, but I did a deep dive on how many condoms come in a pack. How many, like a dozen?
我是说，我觉得有一个范围，但通常是36个。什么？一盒36个？我在网站上看到的。也许那不是真的。我不知道。我们要问萨姆吗？萨姆，你想贡献一下一盒里有多少个吗？
I mean, I feel like there's sort of a range, but normally it's like 36. What? 36 in a pack? That's what I saw on a website. Maybe that's not true. I don't know. Do we go to Sam on this? Sam, do you want to contribute to how many packs are in a pack?
一盒里有多少个避孕套？好吧，我很感激你们总是把毒品或性变态的事情抛给我。我其实不知道这个。哦，好答案，萨姆。好答案。好的，另外，转换话题，迈克尔指出他还想带上他的“有趣牛仔裤”。只是让你们知道，有趣牛仔裤显然是白色的。
How many condoms are in a pack? Well, I do appreciate you guys always throwing to me for drugs or sexual-deviant things. I don't actually know this one. Oh, good answer, Sam. Good answer. Okay, also, switching gears, Michael points out that he also wants to take his fun jeans. Just so you guys know, fun jeans apparently are white.
是的。是的，我想指出他还在干洗他的牛仔裤。是的，它们在袋子里。我们在之前的一集中设定过，我喜欢那个被呼应了。所以安吉拉进来了，她需要迈克尔签收他的每日津贴。
Yes. Yes, I'd like to point out he is still dry cleaning his jeans. Yes, they're in the bag. We set that up in an earlier episode and I love that that got called back. So Angela comes in and she needs Michael to sign for his per diem.
我有两件事想指出。第一，珍娜，你看到我的马尾辫有多俏皮了吗？是的，我后来指出来了。当你在休息室时我注意到了。我实际上把它写下来了。你想知道为什么它看起来那样吗？为什么？好吧，这大约是在整个艾美奖季节、颁奖典礼季节开始的时候，我们去参加派对之类的，我做了一个时髦的头发吹风。周一上班时，我还有很棒的头发。
I have two things I wanna point out. Number one, Jenna, did you see how sassy my ponytail is? Yes, I pointed it out later. I noticed it when you are in the break room. I actually wrote it down. Do you want to know why it looks like that? Why? Well, this was around the beginning of the whole Emmy season, award show season, and we were going to parties and things and I had had a fancy hair blowout. When I came to work on Monday, I still had great day to hair.
所以做头发的金·费里把它扎成了这个马尾辫，它有所有的波浪和质感。她说，我们就这样吧。安吉拉有一个俏皮的马尾辫。所以她之后每天都得配合那个，但这就是为什么我有一个有趣的，我百分之百注意到了。所以现在迈克尔有一个非常有趣的谈话头，但今晚，我有一个问题要问你。这些是我们从未见过的场景，
So Kim Ferry, who did hair, put it up in this ponytail and it had all this wave and texture to it. And she was like, let's just go with it. Angela has a sassy ponytail. And so then she had to match that each day after, but that's why I have a funny, I totally 100% noticed it. So now Michael has a very funny talking head, but tonight, I have a question for you. These are these scenes that we never see,
从未写过的，我希望它们发生过，因为在2分36秒，迈克尔把乔什称为“穷人的迈克尔·斯科特”，或者至少这就是他在我的公寓周围的称呼。珍娜，他是在和公寓单元的邻居谈论乔什·波特吗？就像，他是说，嗯，你知道，穷人的迈克尔·斯科特，他到底有多频繁地在邻居面前喋喋不休地谈论乔什·波特？这很有趣。我甚至没那样听。我听到的是迈克尔可能在自己的公寓墙内
that were never written, that I wish had happened because at two minutes, 36 seconds, Michael refers to Josh as the poor man's Michael Scott, or at least that's how he's known around my condo. Jenna, is he talking about Josh Porter to his neighbors in his condo unit? Like, is he like, well, you know, poor man Michael Scott, like how much is he just jabbering away at his neighbors about Josh Porter? It's funny. I did not even hear it like that. I heard it as maybe something Michael has muttered out loud to himself within
对自己嘟囔的东西。哦，那更可悲。是的，这就是他在迈克尔公寓周围的称呼。在我的脑海里，我看到他像，你知道，在所有邮箱所在的小墙边，他正在打开他的邮箱，有人走过来，他说，哦，穷人的迈克尔·斯科特。我想和吉姆做朋友了。那个人说，是啊，是啊，好吧，再见，迈克尔。好吧，抱歉，那只是逗乐了我。好的，所以现在我们要进入休息室，安吉拉和德怀特，他们站在房间的两端，他们没有看对方。安吉拉很心烦，因为德怀特要去
the walls of his own condo. Oh, that's even sadder. Yeah, that's how he's known around Michael's condo. In my mind, I saw him like, you know, at the little wall where all the mailboxes are, and he's opening his mailbox and someone walks up and he's like, oh, poor man's Michael Scott. I guess friends with Jim now. And the person's like, yeah, yeah, okay, bye, Michael. All right, sorry, that just tickled me. Okay so now we're going to move into the break room Angela and Dwight they're standing on opposite ends of the room they are not looking at each other. Angela is upset that Dwight is going on
这次旅行，因为她真的想和他在一起，但德怀特对这次旅行感到非常兴奋，对他来说，被列为助理区域经理是一个大事件。这是他工作的重要部分。安吉拉，你们站立的方式，你们不看对方的方式，真是让我觉得好笑。你们的角色会一直这样做，好像如果有人走进房间，他们不会对此感到困惑一样。
this trip because she just really wants to spend time with him and but Dwight is so excited to go on this trip it's a big deal for him to be included assistant regional manager. This is like a big part of his job. Angela, it so tickles me how you guys are standing, how you guys aren't looking at each other. Your characters would do this all the time as if people would not be confused by this if they walked in the room.
这次旅行是因为她真的很想和他待在一起，但德怀特对这次旅行感到非常兴奋，能以助理区域经理的身份参与其中对他来说意义重大。这对他工作来说是很重要的一部分。安吉拉，你们站着的方式，你们互不看对方的样子，真的让我觉得很有趣。你们的角色总是这样，好像如果有人走进房间，根本不会对这种情景感到困惑一样。
Now, this is sort of a classic Dwight Angelo moment within the office that I love so much. Here's a little interesting tidbit about this. And this is on the internet, so you can read about it. But there was a different scene at the table read. I believe it was at the table read. It didn't make it into the shooting draft, where I was upset with Dwight that he was going.
这在办公室里算是德怀特和安吉拉的经典时刻，我非常喜欢。关于这个有个有趣的小花絮。网上有相关内容，你们可以去读一读。但在剧本围读时，其实有另一场戏。我相信是在围读会上。那场戏没进拍摄剧本，内容是我对德怀特要离开感到难过。
So that was the same. And Dwight and I have this exchange in the kitchen where I'm upset with Dwight that he was going. So that was the same. And Dwight and I have this exchange in the kitchen where I'm upset with him. And then at the very end, I say, I'm late. And it's like this cliffhanger. I'm late. Yes. It's like, what?
所以那部分是一样的。德怀特和我在厨房里有段对话，我对他要离开感到难过。所以那部分是一样的。德怀特和我在厨房里有段对话，我对他感到难过。然后在最后，我说，我迟到了。就像个悬念。我迟到了。是的。就像是，什么？
Is she pregnant? Yes. OK. That did not end up getting shot. That did not happen. Because I think, Jenna, as soon as we read it out loud, everyone was like, oh, and I think Greg was like, wait, this is okay. Maybe this is too soon. This is too soon, right?
她怀孕了吗？是的。好吧。那场戏最终没拍。没发生。因为我觉得，珍娜，我们一读出来，大家就觉得，哦，我想格雷格当时觉得，等等，这可以吗？也许太早了。这太早了，对吧？
That would have been crazy. That would have been crazy if in this episode Dwight and Angela are already having a baby. And you know, it would have been a weird sort of callback to that time when he asked her sort of in code if she was had any prescriptions, right yeah so anyway needless to say they decided to change their minds Angela was not late she was just upset because she wanted to spend some time with him which I actually think is really sweet yeah you
那太疯狂了。如果在这集里德怀特和安吉拉已经有了孩子，那太疯狂了。你知道，这会是对他之前用暗语问她是否开了处方那次的一个奇怪的回应，对吧，是的，总之不用说，他们决定改变主意，安吉拉没有迟到，她只是因为想和他多待一会儿而难过，我其实觉得这真的很贴心，是的，你
sort of get to see the softer side to her yeah and then I have to bring this up here because so it will make sense you You guys, there are other scenes that we shot that explains how Angela ultimately ends up in the hotel, but they're in the deleted scenes. Yes. There's a whole sort of extra plot line here where Dwight secretly gives you a ticket on the train to meet him. Yeah. I know. He gives her that before he leaves. But in the break room, I have to just share with you guys,
算是看到了她温柔的一面，是的，我必须在这里提一下，这样你们才能听懂，伙计们，我们还拍了其他场景来解释安吉拉最终是如何进入酒店的，但那些都在删减片段里。是的。这里有一整条额外的剧情线，德怀特偷偷给了你一张火车票去见他。是的。我知道。他在离开前给了她。但在休息室里，我必须和你们分享，
this setup of us back to back, and me at the water cooler, and him at the vending machines. We tried a few different positions, and this is the one we settled on. But we got so tickled. We laughed so hard in the scene. Just at how absurd it was.
我们背靠背的这个设置，我在饮水机旁，他在自动售货机旁。我们尝试了几个不同的位置，这是我们最终确定的一个。但我们被逗乐了。我们在那场戏里笑得太厉害了。只是觉得这太荒谬了。
And then also Ken Whittingham really let us play with how long our pause was until I said, are you still there? Yeah. And so there were times where we left a ton of space and we the longer we didn't say anything to each other, but stood back to back the more tickled we got. And then at the very end, Jenna, I'm curious because I know you have the script, but at the very end I say, don't monkey me. You can't wait to get out of here. A R M. And I, I just like walk out all mad. Now I remember I improvised
还有肯·惠廷汉姆真的让我们自己把握停顿的时间，直到我说，你还在那儿吗？是的。所以有时候我们留出了大量的空白，我们彼此不说话的时间越长，背靠背站着，我们就越觉得好笑。然后在最后，珍娜，我很好奇，因为我知道你有剧本，但在最后我说，别耍我。你迫不及待想离开这儿了。A R M。然后我就气呼呼地走开了。现在我记得我是即兴发挥的
that. Oh yeah. That's not in the script. Well, when I rewatched it, I really felt like I heard my accent when I said A R M. I think when you improvise your accent comes out more. A little bit more. Yeah. So there you have it. That's our little secret break room scene. And Angela was almost gonna have Dwight's baby here. Yeah. In an alternate universe. Okay, so now we go to your talking head Angela. Okay, and this has one of my favorite lines Angela. You say in the Martin family we like to say looks like someone took the slow train from Philly and you explain that that's code for checkout the slut. Yeah I am and then I say why are there flies in here? Yes we have a fan question from Cody Gold about your talking head.
那个。哦，是的。那不在剧本里。嗯，当我重看的时候，我真的觉得我听到了我说话时的口音，当我说了A R M的时候。我想当你即兴发挥时，你的口音会更明显。多一点点。是的。所以就是这样。这就是我们的小秘密休息室场景。安吉拉差点就要在这里怀上德怀特的孩子了。是的。在平行宇宙里。好吧，现在我们转到你的访谈镜头，安吉拉。好的，这里有一句我最喜欢的台词，安吉拉。你说在马丁家族，我们喜欢说“看起来有人坐了费城的慢车”，你解释说那是“快看那个荡妇”的暗语。是的，我是，然后我说，为什么这里有苍蝇？是的，我们有一个来自科迪·戈尔德的粉丝提问，关于你的访谈镜头。
In Angela's talking head, she swats at a fly. Was that scripted, or did another bug harass Angela like in the episode, The Fire? First of all, Cody, we love that you called back the bug from the fire episode. Angela, what is the deal? I don't know. I don't know what the deal is with me and flying bugs.
在安吉拉的访谈镜头里，她拍打了一只苍蝇。那是剧本写的，还是像《火灾》那一集一样，有另一只虫子骚扰安吉拉？首先，科迪，我们很喜欢你提到了《火灾》那集里的虫子。安吉拉，到底是怎么回事？我不知道。我不知道我和飞虫之间到底是怎么回事。
Seriously. But I was, because I was wondering about this too. I have the shooting draft. I didn't see anything about a fly. All right, so Jenna, do you remember when we were filming this episode, it was insanely hot. There was this crazy heat wave.
说真的。但我当时，因为我也在想这个问题。我有拍摄剧本。我没看到任何关于苍蝇的内容。好吧，珍娜，你还记得我们拍这一集的时候吗，天气热得离谱。有一场疯狂的热浪。
It was in August. And as a result, there were all of these like flies. I don't know if you remember this. Oh yeah, it was like a fly infestation. I think they were coming in to get out of the heat. I think they were too. I think we'd open the door. The flies were like it's super hot out. Yeah, the flies were like, oh, air conditioning. I'm getting in there. So this talking head, we filmed it right after lunch that day. And you know, whenever we would have
那是在八月。结果，到处都是苍蝇。我不知道你记不记得。哦，是的，就像苍蝇泛滥一样。我想它们是进来躲避酷暑的。我想也是。我想我们一开门。苍蝇就像是，外面太热了。是的，苍蝇就像是，哦，空调。我要进去了。所以这个访谈镜头，我们那天午饭后就拍了。你知道，每当我们
lunch, Jenna, they would leave the doors open longer. Yeah, to kind of air it out. And there were like, five or six of these dudes buzzing around my head the whole time I was doing this talking head. So one time, I just swatted at one while staying in character. And Gene, our writer was in the room with me and that cracked him up. He loved it and he was like, Ange, will you will you swat at flies again? And I was like, okay. So I did it again but this time I ad-libbed the line, why are there flies in here? And then we did another take and I swatted more and I ad-libbed
吃午饭时，珍娜，他们会把门开得更久。是的，为了通风。我做这个访谈镜头的时候，有五六个家伙一直在我的头顶嗡嗡叫。所以有一次，我只是在保持角色状态的同时拍打了一只。我们的编剧吉恩当时和我在一起，这让他笑坏了。他很喜欢，他说，安吉，你愿意再拍打一次苍蝇吗？我说，好的。所以我又拍了一次，但这次我即兴加了一句台词，为什么这里有苍蝇？然后我们又拍了一遍，我拍得更多，我又即兴发挥了
that, you know what, this is all Kevin's fault. He had smelly takeout and I did this whole really mean riff on Kevin's food that attracted the flies. That did not make it in. But my other improv line did. Oh my God. That is amazing. But here's the thing, Angela, I'll have you know, none of your talking head that is in the script is the same as the episode.
那个，你知道吗，这全是凯文的错。他带了味道很大的外卖，我针对凯文的食物做了一整段非常刻薄的即兴发挥，吸引了苍蝇。那段没进正片。但我的另一句即兴台词进去了。天哪。那太棒了。但问题是，安吉拉，我要告诉你，你的访谈镜头里没有一句是和剧本一样的。
I looked it up. What? So the slow train from Philly isn't in the script? Slow train from Philly is not in the script either. Fly is not in the script. Slow train from Philly not in the script. Here is what your talking head was supposed to be. Oh my gosh. Yeah, I want to hear it. Here it is. Yes. Michael and Dwight Schrute are going to a convention in Philadelphia. Personally, I find even the idea of a convention repulsive.
我查过了。什么？所以“费城的慢车”不在剧本里？“费城的慢车”也不在剧本里。苍蝇也不在剧本里。“费城的慢车”不在剧本里。这是你原本的访谈镜头内容。天哪。是的，我想听听。就是这个。是的。迈克尔和德怀特·施鲁特要去费城参加会议。个人而言，我甚至觉得会议这个概念就很令人反感。
All those people from different places gathered together, breathing hot breath all over each other. It's disgusting. Did you like my attempt to read it as Angela Martin? I loved it, I loved it. I remember when we were doing this talking head, Jane and Lee handed me a page of alts, Jenna. I had a huge alt list.
所有那些来自不同地方的人聚在一起，对着彼此呼出热气。太恶心了。你喜欢我尝试用安吉拉·马丁的语气读它吗？我喜欢，我喜欢。我记得我们做这个访谈镜头时，简和李给了我一页备选台词，珍娜。我有一个巨大的备选清单。
We called it the candy bag, you remember. Oh yeah, yeah, no. When we would do our talking heads, we would have the one that was in the script. But then as soon as we sat down in the chair, they would hand us pages of alternate talking heads. And sometimes the alternates made it in the show, and sometimes it was the scripted version.
我们叫它糖果袋，你记得吗。哦，是的，是的，不。当我们做访谈镜头时，我们会用剧本里的那一个。但一旦我们坐在椅子上，他们就会递给我们几页备选的访谈镜头。有时备选的会出现在节目里，有时是剧本里的版本。
Exactly, and this is the perfect example of that. Lee and Jean, our writers from this episode, gave me a page of alts. Clearly, Slow Train from Philly won. Everyone loved that. I improvised the line about the flies because flies were literally buzzing my head the whole time. And that's how we got this talking head. Cody, we loved your question. So now, Kelly comes up to Pam's desk. Guys, she's full Mindy. She's very excited because she has set up Pam with her neighbor, Alan. Yes, I was going to play my sting, which sounds like this.
没错，这就是完美的例子。李和吉恩，我们这一集的编剧，给了我一页备选。显然，“费城的慢车”胜出了。大家都喜欢那个。关于苍蝇的台词是我即兴发挥的，因为苍蝇当时真的在我头顶嗡嗡叫。这就是我们得到这个访谈镜头的方式。科迪，我们很喜欢你的问题。现在，凯利走到帕姆的桌子旁。伙计们，她完全是明迪附体。她非常兴奋，因为她给帕姆安排了和她的邻居艾伦见面。是的，我要播放我的音效，听起来像这样。
Full Mindy! Yeah, you got to get your stings in. Angela, I've got a few. I've got a few for this episode. You got to get yours in. When I say play my sting, it's just me doing it. There's no button. I'm not hitting a button.
完全是明迪！是的，你得把你的音效放出来。安吉拉，我有几个。这一集我有几个。你得把你的放出来。当我说播放我的音效时，只是我在做。没有按钮。我没按按钮。
Well, Pam has this talking head where she explains that Alan is a cartoonist for the local paper. He likes to draw. She's kind of nervous because she has not been on a first date in nine years. And then she she says probably shouldn't broadcast that. And I don't know why, Jenna, it just tickled me that Pam would say broadcast. Like really, I don't know why. It just seemed like such like an old lady term. Don't broadcast it.
嗯，帕姆有个访谈镜头，解释说艾伦是当地报纸的漫画家。他喜欢画画。她有点紧张，因为她九年没约会过了。然后她说，可能不该广播这件事。我不知道为什么，珍娜，帕姆会说“广播”这件事让我觉得很好笑。真的，我不知道为什么。这听起来像个老太太的词。别广播它。
I don't know. Well, of course, Michael is leaving now for Philadelphia and he overhears that Pam is going on this date and Kelly tells Pam not to sleep with Alan on the first date but Michael tells Pam that she should unbutton her blouse a little bit. Let those guys breathe doesn't he say something like that? Let them breathe. He's always wanting them to breathe or set them free. He's very concerned about your Tatas being confined. So people wrote in and wanted to know if the um sort of like song and dance of Michael and Dwight as they're leaving the office, if that was scripted or if those guys just
我不知道。嗯，当然，迈克尔现在要出发去费城了，他无意中听到帕姆要去约会，凯利告诉帕姆第一次约会不要和艾伦发生关系，但迈克尔告诉帕姆她应该把衬衫扣子解开一点。让那些家伙透透气，他不是说了类似的话吗？让它们透透气。他总是希望它们透透气或者释放它们。他非常关心你的胸部被束缚。所以有人写信来问，迈克尔和德怀特离开办公室时的那种歌舞，是剧本写的，还是那些家伙自己
made that up, they totally made that up. They totally made that up. There is a stage direction after they give her grief for saying um and then it just says they both laugh and walk out the door. Yes. and then it just says they both laugh and walk out the door. Yes, so that whole that that whole out the door business that was them having fun for sure. Well, one of the things I really
编出来的，他们完全是自己编的。他们完全是自己编的。在他们因为她说“嗯”而责备她之后，有一个舞台指示，然后写着他们都笑了，走出了门。是的。然后写着他们都笑了，走出了门。是的，所以那整个出门的戏份，肯定是他们玩得很开心。嗯，我真正
remember about this episode once I got to the hotel where we were filming is those guys were like. They were like kids in the candy jar. They were having so much fun, just all riffing off each other, and I think they really did when they would get together,
记得关于这一集的一件事是，一旦我到了我们拍摄的酒店，那些家伙就像。他们就像糖果罐里的孩子。他们玩得太开心了，都在互相即兴发挥，我觉得他们真的在他们聚在一起的时候，
especially John, Rain, and Steve, they would just get giddy. There is so much improvisation that happens at the convention. We will get there, but yes, you're right, you're right. All right, so now Angela, we have this scene in the kitchen. Creed comes up to you and he asks you how he can get a little of that per diem money.
尤其是约翰、雷恩和史蒂夫，他们会变得很兴奋。会议期间发生了太多的即兴表演。我们会讲到那里的，但是的，你是对的，你是对的。好吧，现在安吉拉，我们在厨房有这场戏。克里德走到你身边，问你他怎么能弄到一点那种每日津贴。
Yeah. Right? So then Meredith makes a comment that the whole town of Philadelphia just smells like cheese steaks. And for whatever reason, Angela, you are very offended by this. Yes, I say that town is full of history and I get up and I storm out and I leave my food Jenna. Sam can I get my sting? Oh good God. Where's the beef? Where's the beef? Where's the beef? I'll tell you where the beef is Angela.
是的。对吧？然后梅雷迪思评论说整个费城小镇闻起来都是芝士牛排的味道。不管出于什么原因，安吉拉，你对此感到非常冒犯。是的，我说那个小镇充满了历史，然后我站起来冲了出去，把我的食物留下了，珍娜。萨姆，我能要我的音效吗？哦，天哪。牛肉在哪里？牛肉在哪里？牛肉在哪里？我会告诉你牛肉在哪里，安吉拉。
You have beef with beef? I have a beef and I'm not the only one. Oh my Lord. Megan Keller wrote in to say, wrote a question. But in the ho laughed when Pam got up a Roy says if he wasn't dat Katie out. But at four mi walks away from her serial
你对牛肉有意见？我有意见，而且我不止一个。哦，天哪。梅根·凯勒写信来说，写了一个问题。但在酒店里，当帕姆站起来时，罗伊说如果他没在和凯蒂约会的话……但在四分钟时，她从她的食物旁走开了。
away from her food. Sarah Donaldson says, Jenna, can you please give Angela some what's for after the hard time she gave Pam first storming off and leaving her plate of food when Angela does the same thing at four minutes 55 seconds. All right, Angela. All right, I have a beef. Fine. Fine. Okay, fine. I get it, I get it. Apparently on this show, if you get ticked off enough at someone,
从她的食物旁走开。莎拉·唐纳森说，珍娜，你能给安吉拉一些教训吗，因为她之前因为帕姆冲走并留下盘子里的食物而给了帕姆难堪，而安吉拉在四分五十五秒时做了同样的事。好吧，安吉拉。好吧，我有意见。行。行。好吧，行。我明白了，我明白了。显然在这个节目里，如果你对某人生气到一定程度，
you just get up and you leave your food. Fine, okay, fine. I'm sorry, everybody. I am sorry. My character does it too. I apologize. I apologize. But let me just say,
你就会站起来留下你的食物。行，好吧，行。对不起，大家。我很抱歉。我的角色也这么做了。我道歉。我道歉。但让我说，
in the moment when you were taping that scene, did you stop and say, guys, I'm so sorry, this isn't realistic, I would never just storm away and leave my cereal here. But you actually had to leave your cereal there because Creed's going to start eating it. Creed is going to start eating it, which is hilarious. And then he has one of his all time favorite lines.
在拍摄那场戏的时候，你有没有停下来问，伙计们，我很抱歉，这不现实，我绝不会就这样冲走并把我的麦片留在这里。但你确实不得不把麦片留在那里，因为克里德要开始吃了。克里德要开始吃了，这太搞笑了。然后他说了他有史以来最喜欢的台词之一。
He has told me this is one of his favorite lines from the whole series. That's Andrea, the office bitch. You'll get used to her. And then he introduces himself to Meredith. Exactly, exactly. And then I have to point out my character, she's sort of being a hypocrite because earlier she's like, well, you know, Code for Slut is like someone who looks like they took the slow train to Philly. So Philly is like not a good place.
他告诉我这是他整个系列中最喜欢的台词之一。那是安德里亚，办公室的婊子。你会习惯她的。然后他向梅雷迪思介绍了自己。没错，没错。然后我必须指出我的角色，她有点虚伪，因为早些时候她说，嗯，你知道，“荡妇”的暗语是看起来像坐了费城慢车的人。所以费城好像不是个好地方。
But then here she's like it's full of history. All right. Now it's five minutes 10 seconds and Dwight and Michael are on the train. They are headed to Philadelphia. That's right. Michael has his headphones on. He has Dwight's neck pillow, which he pretends he can't hear Dwight asking for. I have some fun facts about this.
但在这里她又说它充满了历史。好吧。现在是五分十秒，德怀特和迈克尔在火车上。他们正前往费城。没错。迈克尔戴着耳机。他拿着德怀特的颈枕，假装听不到德怀特在要它。关于这个我有一些有趣的事实。
On Dunderpedia, it says that there is no passenger rail service between Scranton and Philadelphia, and maybe that was true back in the day when we shot this. But today, I looked it up, Amtrak does offer two trains per day, takes about three hours to get to Philadelphia from Scranton by train and tickets start at $41. Well, I would think that there would be a train.
在邓德百科上，它说斯克兰顿和费城之间没有客运铁路服务，也许在我们拍摄的时候那是真的。但今天，我查了一下，美铁每天提供两班火车，从斯克兰顿坐火车到费城大约需要三个小时，票价从41美元起。嗯，我会觉得应该有火车的。
That makes sense. It does. So yes. So now there is a train. I went to Kentopedia because I was fascinated by the fact that we shot on an actual Amtrak train because we did. That was not like some fancy weird green screen thing happening. That was a train.
这说得通。确实。所以是的。所以现在有火车了。我去了肯特百科，因为我对我们是在真正的美铁火车上拍摄的事实很着迷，因为我们确实是。那不是什么花哨的奇怪绿幕特效。那是一列火车。
So here's what Kent told me, Ange. What? I want to hear it. They let us shoot on the train for free. For free? Yes. But we had to agree that we would not disrupt their schedule in any way. So on day two of film and the production design
所以这是肯特告诉我的，安吉。什么？我想听听。他们免费让我们在火车上拍摄。免费？是的。但我们必须同意我们不会以任何方式干扰他们的时间表。所以在拍摄的第二天，制作设计
up the hotel room at the rain and a very small cr extras, they loaded into drove to the Simi Valley boarded the caboose car a were given the caboose ca They got settled. The train started moving. Kent said they got their first shot off at 1103.
在火车上布置了酒店房间，还有很少的临时演员，他们装载进去，开车到西米谷，登上了守车，他们得到了守车。他们安顿下来。火车开始移动。肯特说他们在11点03分拍到了第一个镜头。
Then when the train arrived at the Burbank Airport station at 1127, they got off the train and there were vans waiting to pick them up and take them back to our main set. And that's how we got that train stuff. Is that safe? I like what like specific details that Kent gave you? It's amazing. Kintapedia, you are amazing.
然后当火车在11点27分到达伯班克机场站时，他们下了火车，有货车等着接他们回我们的主片场。这就是我们得到那些火车镜头的方式。那安全吗？我喜欢肯特给你的那些具体细节？太神奇了。肯特百科，你太棒了。
One of the reasons why Kent and I are friends is because I so fully appreciate the detail that he has kept in a way that I'm not sure many other people would. I know, you do. I'm like. You do. Kent and I are of a similar mind with our spreadsheets
肯特和我成为朋友的原因之一是因为我非常欣赏他保留细节的方式，我不确定还有多少人会这样做。我知道，你做到了。我像。你做到了。肯特和我的想法很像，我们的电子表格
in order. We love it. Well you guys there are some other deleted scenes from the train that are really funny so you go to the DVD set if you have them. They're funny. All right well then they're gonna arrive in Philly. They're gonna greet Josh and Jim. They're reunited. They're reunited. Dwight and Michael and Josh and Jim. I have a little bit of a background catch. Oh give it. All right at five minutes 34 seconds Dwight is wearing his name tag. You know they have these lanyards around their neck right? Yeah. Dwight is wearing his and then at five minutes 59 seconds he's putting it on and it's got all this writing on it. Like he's got all of his phone numbers in Sharpie.
井井有条。我们喜欢它。好吧，伙计们，还有一些来自火车的删减片段真的很有趣，所以如果你有DVD套装的话可以去看看。它们很有趣。好吧，然后他们会到达费城。他们会迎接乔什和吉姆。他们团聚了。他们团聚了。德怀特和迈克尔，乔什和吉姆。我有一个小小的背景发现。哦，说吧。好吧，在五分三十四秒，德怀特戴着他的名牌。你知道他们脖子上挂着挂绳，对吧？是的。德怀特戴着他的，然后在五分五十九秒，他把它戴上，上面写满了字。就像他用记号笔写了他的所有电话号码。
He's got his cell phone, his home, his pager. He's got his room number five, five, six on there. And he has written in a little assistant. He wrote in a little arrow. So it's like assistant to the regional manager. He like changed his like title. Oh my gosh, that is amazing. So they're all reunited now at the convention and this was calculated. They knew that they needed to keep Jim and Pam apart by sending Jim to Stanford, but they did not want to keep Jim
他写了手机、家庭电话、寻呼机。他在上面写了房间号五五六。他还写了一个小小的“助理”。他写了一个小箭头。所以就像“区域经理助理”。他改了他的头衔。天哪，那太神奇了。所以他们现在在会议上团聚了，这是经过计算的。他们知道他们需要通过把吉姆送到斯坦福来让吉姆和帕姆分开，但他们不想让吉姆
from interacting with Dwight and Michael. So that was kind of the reason for this whole episode was to get Jim back in the world with these other characters but still separate him from Pam who is back at the office dealing with her own stuff. All right I have two things Jenna that I think will be kind of fun that we clock we like to track things guys at 6 minutes 15 seconds. Oh, there's a good, good example of Jim saying, D White. Ooh, there's a D White? Yes, Jim has a talking head and John says D White.
和德怀特及迈克尔互动。所以这一集的全部原因就是让吉姆回到这些角色所在的圈子里，但仍然让他和在办公室处理自己事情的帕姆分开。好吧，我有两件事，珍娜，我觉得会很有趣，我们记录下来，我们喜欢追踪事情，伙计们，在六分十五秒。哦，这是一个很好的例子，吉姆说，“D White”。哦，有个“D White”？是的，吉姆有个访谈镜头，约翰说了“D White”。
It's like, it's huge. So there you go. I love to track it when he says D White. And then back in the office at six minutes, 31 seconds. Well, some big information is revealed to Toby about Pam. Yeah. Jenna, what you are now. Pam is like the the hot new meat in the office. Yeah, she's back on the market.
就像是，太棒了。所以就是这样。我喜欢追踪他说“D White”的时候。然后回到办公室，在六分三十一秒。嗯，关于帕姆的一些重大信息透露给了托比。是的。珍娜，你现在是什么。帕姆就像办公室里炙手可热的新鲜肉。是的，她又回到单身市场了。
Kevin. Kevin says that if he wasn't engaged, he would quote. So hit that. Kevin, gross. Guess what I wrote down? Tracking the perv. Tracking the Kevin perv. This is Kevin perv. Six minutes, 31 seconds, Kevin perv. But the look that Paul Lee Rusty does as Toby. That look is gold. Oh my gosh. Toby has it so bad for Pam. I know. I know. And then Pam is in the kitchen and she's reading some of Alan's cartoons. Her blind date, Alan. I'm sorry. Is Pam prepping for for her date Jenna? Is this a little bit of Jenna and Pam like oh I have a date with this person I'm going to deep dive. Is Pam doing a deep dive? I don't know if reading his cartoons and the page she's taking an interest. She hasn't been on a date in nine years
凯文。凯文说如果他没订婚的话，他会引用“搞定她”。凯文，恶心。猜猜我写下了什么？追踪色狼。追踪凯文色狼。这是凯文色狼。六分三十一秒，凯文色狼。但保罗·李·拉斯蒂作为托比表现出的那个眼神。那个眼神是金子。天哪。托比对帕姆真是太着迷了。我知道。我知道。然后帕姆在厨房里，她在读艾伦的一些漫画。她的相亲对象，艾伦。抱歉。帕姆是在为她的约会做准备吗，珍娜？这有点像珍娜和帕姆，哦，我要和这个人约会，我要深入了解一下。帕姆是在深入挖掘吗？我不知道读他的漫画和页面是不是在表现出兴趣。她九年没约会过了
she's trying to she's doing her due diligence and Kelly enters and she gushes about how smart his cartoons are that she doesn't even understand them sometimes. And then Toby walks in the kitchen and he kind of tries to get Pam's attention but no she's not clocking Toby. It just when I watched him try to he tries to wave she doesn't notice and then he goes in the bathroom. The track that I could hear was totally it's like totally like the sad scene from like peanuts. Alright well then we go back to the convention and Michael and Dwight are setting up their hotel room they've got a mini dartboard they've got some booze. And Michael has strategically asked for and chosen a room
她试图，她在做尽职调查，凯利走进厨房，她滔滔不绝地说他的漫画有多聪明，她有时甚至看不懂。然后托比走进厨房，他试图引起帕姆的注意，但没有，她没注意到托比。当我看到他试图挥手时，她没注意到，然后他进了洗手间。我能听到的配乐完全就像是《花生》里那种悲伤的场景。好吧，然后我们回到会议，迈克尔和德怀特正在布置他们的酒店房间，他们有一个迷你飞镖盘，他们有一些酒。迈克尔战略性地要求并选择了一个
close to the elevator because he thinks that he'll get more foot traffic that way. Yeah, he thought about it and he he knows. Hopefully it wasn't by the service elevator. Yeah, this is true. Who wants the room by the elevator Michael but he's ready for you know, he's ready to party Jenna. Because there ain't no party like a Scranton party because Scranton party don't stop what? Yeah, Scranton party
靠近电梯的房间，因为他认为那样会有更多的人流量。是的，他考虑过了，他知道。希望那不是在服务电梯旁边。是的，这是真的。谁想要电梯旁边的房间，迈克尔，但他准备好了，你知道，他准备好派对了，珍娜。因为没有派对像斯克兰顿派对，因为斯克兰顿派对不会停止，什么？是的，斯克兰顿派对
because Scranton party don't stop what? You know it. Jim and Josh come by and they think that they should get to their meeting with Jan. Yeah. Right. I mean they are here to work. They're here to work but Michael is like, come on. You've got time for shots and then Jim and Josh have an inside joke. A shot of Midori. Jim and Josh have this inside joke and they start cracking up and then Michael and Dwight so desperately want to be a part of this they start laughing really hard like too hard.
因为斯克兰顿派对不会停止，什么？你知道的。吉姆和乔什过来了，他们认为他们应该去参加和简的会议。是的。对吧？我的意思是他们是来工作的。他们是来工作的，但迈克尔说，来吧。你们有时间喝一杯，然后吉姆和乔什有个内部笑话。一杯Midori酒。吉姆和乔什有这个内部笑话，他们开始大笑，然后迈克尔和德怀特非常渴望成为其中的一部分，他们开始大笑，笑得太厉害了。
Yeah. They have no idea what they're laughing at and it's so embarrassing when Jim's like no actually is inside joke. Yeah. You would not actually laugh at that. You don't know what we're talking about. And then Michael has that sad sad line that he loves inside jokes and he's always wanted to be a part of one.
是的。他们根本不知道自己在笑什么，当吉姆说“不，其实这是内部笑话”时，太尴尬了。是的。你不会真的因为那个而笑。你不知道我们在说什么。然后迈克尔说了那句悲伤的台词，他喜欢内部笑话，他一直想成为其中的一部分。
Yeah. I wish I was. I love inside jokes. I'd love to be a part of one someday. Now I want to point something out here. What Michael and Dwight are wearing matching gray Dunder Mifflin shirts. And then Jim and Josh are wearing kind of matching light colored shirts. They're wearing light and downs. Well, one of them has like a slight pink hue to it.
是的。我希望我是。我喜欢内部笑话。我希望有一天能成为其中的一部分。现在我想指出一点。迈克尔和德怀特穿着配套的灰色邓德·米夫林衬衫。然后吉姆和乔什穿着某种配套的浅色衬衫。他们穿着浅色衬衫。嗯，其中一件有一点点粉色调。
And I feel like Johns has a slight yellow hue to it. Maybe that's just my computer monitor. I do as I watch this on my computer. I just say They were not exactly matching to me, which actually I felt like made it even cooler because they're like, you know what? Just any light colored button down will do just make it a light color cream off white white light pink light yellow anything there. They are
我觉得约翰的那件有一点点黄色调。也许那只是我的电脑显示器。我在电脑上看这个的时候。我只是说它们对我来说并不完全匹配，这实际上让我觉得更酷，因为他们就像，你知道吗？任何浅色的衬衫都可以，只要是浅色，奶油色、灰白色、白色、浅粉色、浅黄色，什么都行。他们就在那里
strategically unbuttoned at the exact same place. Maybe that's just where all men unbutton their shirts. But I found it a little odd. I don't know. Check it out. But I want to say something about those gray Dunder Mifflin shirts that Dwight and Michael are wearing. OK, after this episode, I went to Kerry Bennett and I asked if she had any extras and she gave me one and I sent it to my dad. Oh
战略性地在同一个地方解开了扣子。也许这就是所有男人解开衬衫扣子的地方。但我发现这有点奇怪。我不知道。去看看吧。但我想说一下德怀特和迈克尔穿的那件灰色邓德·米夫林衬衫。好的，这一集之后，我去找了凯莉·贝内特，问她有没有多余的，她给了我一件，我寄给了我爸爸。哦
Now this was before you could buy them. This was before Dunder Mifflin merchandise was out there and He used to wear it around He was an engineer a plastics engineer and he went on the road a lot and he would have to visit factories To help them with troubleshooting issues with their production line. Okay. So he traveled a lot and he would wear it when he traveled to these factories and people would say, Oh, Dunder Mifflin paper company. What is that? And he would just, he would smile and he would just say, Oh, that's, um, that's the company my, where my daughter works.
这还是在你买到它们之前。这还是在邓德·米夫林周边产品出来之前，他过去常穿着它。他是一名工程师，塑料工程师，他经常出差，他必须去工厂帮助他们解决生产线的问题。好的。所以他经常出差，他去这些工厂时会穿它，人们会说，哦，邓德·米夫林造纸公司。那是什么？他会微笑，然后说，哦，那是，嗯，那是我的女儿工作的公司。
Oh, look at your dad being coy, but so proud. That's so cute. But then some people would put it together and then he would be so excited and he would be like, Oh, well, my daughter gave it to me. Oh, your daughter gave it to you. Where did she get it? Oh, she has an in. She, um, she's the receptionist there. And they would be like, wait, what? Yeah.
哦，看你爸爸装傻，但又那么骄傲。太可爱了。但有些人会猜到，然后他会非常兴奋，他说，哦，好吧，是我女儿给我的。哦，你女儿给你的？她从哪儿弄来的？哦，她在那儿有门路。她，嗯，她是那儿的前台。他们会说，等等，什么？是的。
He was so proud. My dad is so cute. My dad was the same way he would, um, any photo from anything I was in. I mean, anything, uh, he would either screen grab it or find a way to print it or get a copy of it but he would always make the photo so big and he'd hang it on the wall and I would go home and there'd be a photo like Jenna of you and I at some you know event it'd be just like some little thing you and I had some, you know, event, it'd be just like some little thing you and I were doing.
他太骄傲了。我爸爸太可爱了。我爸爸也是一样，他会，嗯，任何我参与的照片。我的意思是，任何东西，呃，他要么截图，要么想办法打印出来，或者弄个副本，但他总是把照片弄得很大，挂在墙上，我回家时，就会有照片，就像珍娜，你和我在一起的某个，你知道，活动，那只是我和你做的一些小事，你知道，活动，那只是我和你做的一些小事。
There were photos with you. I don't know that I've ever shared this with you, but there are photos of you in my parents' home that my dad printed up. Jenna, you're like 8 by 12, 11 by 14. They're humongous photos of us on the wall. Oh my God. I love that. But you get it right.
有你的照片。我不知道我有没有和你分享过这个，但我父母家里有你照片，是我爸爸打印出来的。珍娜，你就像8乘12，11乘14那么大。墙上有我们巨大的照片。天哪。我喜欢这个。但你懂的，对吧。
Could you imagine if one of your kids was on a TV show? I feel like I would do the same thing. Oh, yeah. I would collect everything. I would save everything. Parents are the best. Call your parents. OK, so nine minutes, 13 seconds. Michael and Dwight are at the convention. There's some really great shots now of all the vendors
你能想象如果你的孩子在电视节目里吗？我觉得我会做同样的事。哦，是的。我会收集一切。我会保存一切。父母是最棒的。给你的父母打电话。好的，九分十三秒。迈克尔和德怀特在会议上。现在有一些所有供应商的精彩镜头
and you really get a sense of how big this room was. Michael is going around to all the booths and guys, he is really into swag. He's really into the freebies. He's got like a foam finger. I don't know, some shirts, a lanyard or two, some sunglasses. He's got all kinds of stuff. I want to say this talking head is not in the script.
你真的能感觉到这个房间有多大。迈克尔正在逛所有的展位，伙计们，他真的很喜欢赠品。他真的很喜欢免费的东西。他有一个泡沫手指。我不知道，一些衬衫，一两个挂绳，一些太阳镜。他有各种各样的东西。我想说这个访谈镜头不在剧本里。
Also Jenna, at 9 minutes 12 seconds we get to see a really fun cameo. It's Jerome Bettis. Yes, the bus. The bus. This was huge. Guys, to give you some context on Jerome Bettis, in case you don't know, Jerome Bettis is a former NFL halfback who played for the Rams when they were both in St. Louis and in Los Angeles.
还有珍娜，在九分十二秒，我们看到了一个非常有趣的客串。是杰罗姆·贝蒂斯。是的，公交车。公交车。这太大了。伙计们，为了给你们一些关于杰罗姆·贝蒂斯的背景，以防你们不知道，杰罗姆·贝蒂斯是一位前NFL半卫，他在圣路易斯和洛杉矶时都为公羊队效力。
And he also played for the Pittsburgh Steelers. We shot this episode in August 2006. That February, the Pittsburgh Steelers won the Super Bowl. Jerome Betis retired after that game, like literally at the game. They won the Super Bowl. He gave an interview and was like, and now I'm retiring. So here's how this went down. I asked Kentopedia. Jerome Betis had just been hired by NBC Sports as a commentator. And Angela, do you remember our NBC rep Vernon Sanders? Of course I love Vernon!
他也为匹兹堡钢人队效力。我们是在2006年8月拍摄这一集的。那年二月，匹兹堡钢人队赢得了超级碗。杰罗姆·贝蒂斯在那场比赛后退役了，就像字面意义上在比赛中。他们赢得了超级碗。他接受了采访，说，现在我要退役了。所以事情是这样的。我问了肯特百科。杰罗姆·贝蒂斯刚被NBC体育聘为评论员。安吉拉，你还记得我们的NBC代表弗农·桑德斯吗？当然，我爱弗农！
Love Vernon. Vernon called Greg and Kent and said, what do you think about a little crossover thing here where Jerome Bettis does a cameo at the convention. Greg loved the idea and got together. They wrote a scene like on the fly and then they shot it on day four of the shoot. It's so perfect too. It's so perfect that Michael would invite him to his party and then want him to commit to coming.
爱弗农。弗农打电话给格雷格和肯特，说，你们觉得在这里做一个小小的交叉，让杰罗姆·贝蒂斯在会议上客串一下怎么样。格雷格很喜欢这个主意，聚在一起。他们临时写了一个场景，然后在拍摄的第四天拍了它。这也太完美了。迈克尔邀请他参加他的派对，然后想让他承诺会来，这太完美了。
Can I tell people you're coming? Oh, so good. All right, so Jenna, I have a question for you since you have the script. As Dwight and Michael are walking away from Jerome, Dwight says, why do they call him the bus? And I swear I heard Michael say because he doesn't like to fly. Yeah, that was scripted. That was scripted.
我能告诉别人你要来吗？哦，太好了。好吧，珍娜，我有个问题要问你，因为你有剧本。当德怀特和迈克尔从杰罗姆身边走开时，德怀特说，为什么他们叫他“公交车”？我发誓我听到迈克尔说因为他不喜欢坐飞机。是的，那是剧本写的。那是剧本写的。
That exchange was scripted. Yeah. His nickname was the bus. Yeah. And the reason his nickname was the bus was because he had this ability to keep running down the field while carrying other players on his back through people. Basically, he got you like if you grabbed onto him, he could keep on going. He just kept going. Yes. But Michael, Michael thinks it's because he doesn't like to fly. Yes, exactly. Well, I just want to round this out by telling you guys a few things when I was deep diving on Jerome Bettis. He seems like a super great guy.
那段对话是剧本写的。是的。他的绰号是“公交车”。是的。他绰号叫“公交车”的原因是因为他有这种能力，在背着其他球员穿过人群时还能继续在场上奔跑。基本上，他让你，如果你抓住他，他还能继续前进。他只是继续前进。是的。但迈克尔，迈克尔认为是因为他不喜欢坐飞机。是的，没错。好吧，我只是想通过告诉你们一些我在深入挖掘杰罗姆·贝蒂斯时发现的事情来总结一下。他看起来是个超级棒的人。
He was inducted into the Pro Football Hall of Fame in 2015 and he has the Jerome Bettis Bus Stop Here Foundation, which is dedicated to improving the overall quality of life for troubled and underprivileged inner city youth. And he has delivered over 1,000 pairs of cleats to children in the Detroit school system. So he's a good guy. Jerome, just so you know, if you ever hear this, we tried to figure out how to contact you, but we couldn't figure it out. We wanted, you know, to give you a little love and ask you a few questions. But but we couldn't figure it out
他在2015年入选了职业橄榄球名人堂，他有“杰罗姆·贝蒂斯公交车在此停靠”基金会，致力于改善陷入困境和贫困的内城青年的整体生活质量。他为底特律学校系统的孩子们提供了超过1000双防滑鞋。所以他是个好人。杰罗姆，只要你知道，如果你听到这个，我们试着想办法联系你，但我们没能弄清楚。我们想，你知道，给你一点爱并问你几个问题。但我们没能弄清楚
So if Jenna slid into your DMS no red flags. She was just wanting to talk to you about this episode Oh the number of DMS I've slid into for this show Angela. No, no It's a lot. So now you're gonna just see some wide shots of the convention and Michael walking around and he goes up to a Blackberry phone mascot, right? Yeah. So it does someone in a Blackberry costume and he's just starts messing with them and he even invites them to the party. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question from Rebecca Spector and Lauren Wood. They both want to know who was in the cell phone mascot costume. I want to know that too.
所以如果珍娜滑进了你的私信，没有危险信号。她只是想和你谈谈这一集。哦，为了这个节目我滑进的私信数量，安吉拉。不，不。很多。所以现在你会看到一些会议的广角镜头，迈克尔走来走去，他走到一个黑莓手机吉祥物旁边，对吧？是的。所以有人穿着黑莓服装，他开始逗他们，甚至邀请他们参加派对。是的。嗯，我们有一个来自丽贝卡·斯佩克特和劳伦·伍德的粉丝提问。她们都想知道谁穿着手机吉祥物服装。我也想知道。
Yeah, so there is some lore. There are some office lore that it was Phil Shea. Well, that's what I thought. Yeah, I reached out to Phil. He said he was not in the Blackberry costume. He said he had a contact at R.A.M. Technology, which are the people who make Blackberry, and he got them to send over someone from their company with the Blackberry costume, and that's who it was.
是的，所以有一些传说。有一些办公室传说说是菲尔·谢。嗯，我也是这么想的。是的，我联系了菲尔。他说他没穿黑莓服装。他说他在R.A.M.技术公司有联系人，那是制造黑莓的公司，他让他们从公司派了一个人穿着黑莓服装过来，就是那个人。
Oh, well, it was an official, an official Blackberry mascot. It wasn't us pretending to be the mascot person. It was the official mascot. Oh, that's right. Yeah. Okay. There you go. So should we go back to Dunder Mifflin and see Pam and Toby again? Should we visit Pam and Toby and Toby's awkward attempt to ask Pam out? Yeah. Oh it's so sad. He walks up to her desk and she gets a phone call. And he waits and waits. And he loses his nerve. And he can't do it.
哦，好吧，那是一个官方的，官方的黑莓吉祥物。不是我们假装成吉祥物。那是官方吉祥物。哦，原来如此。是的。好吧。就是这样。那我们回到邓德·米夫林，再看看帕姆和托比吧？我们要去看看帕姆和托比，以及托比笨拙地试图约帕姆出去吗？是的。哦，太悲伤了。他走到她的桌子旁，她接了个电话。他等啊等。他失去了勇气。他做不到。
Now, while he's losing his nerve, did you notice that Paul drums his fingers on the reception desk? And remember when I told you guys that Paul would do this? He was a drummer. Oh yeah. So here he does it.
现在，当他失去勇气时，你注意到保罗在接待台敲手指了吗？还记得我告诉过你们保罗会这样做吗？他是个鼓手。哦，是的。所以他在这里做了。
He drums at reception while he's waiting for Pam. It's just something that Paul does naturally. So I don't even know that he really realized he was doing it. I know he was showing that Toby was nervous and anxious. But that movement that you see his hands do, he used to do all the time. Well, we had a couple of fans write in with a catch at 10 minutes,
他在等待帕姆时在接待处敲击。这只是保罗自然而然会做的事情。所以我甚至不知道他是否真的意识到自己在做。我知道他在表现托比的紧张和焦虑。但你看到他手做的那个动作，他过去经常做。嗯，我们有几个粉丝写信来指出在十分
35 seconds. What Bailey Aspinson said, why are there the times and names of TV shows on a post-it note at reception? Oh yeah. And Claudia Cano said there are two post-it notes on Pam's desk. One says seven to 8 PM, Big Brother, CBS. 8 to 9 PM, Animal Planet, Jane Goodall returns. A&E, first 48 hours. And then there's a second post-it note, which reads,
三十五秒的一个发现。贝利·阿斯平森说，为什么接待处的一张便利贴上有电视节目的时间和名字？哦，是的。克劳迪娅·卡诺说帕姆的桌子上有两张便利贴。一张写着晚上七点到八点，老大哥，CBS。八点到九点，动物星球，珍·古道尔回归。A&E，前48小时。然后有第二张便利贴，上面写着，
facts, Jan, David, and Connie. So she wrote, my two questions are, are those a list of TV shows that Pam watches? And my second question is who is Connie? So I looked at these. These are both in my handwriting. I don't know. I don't know who Connie is. I clearly just threw that in there as a little bit of, I don't know, spice. And guys, that was a list of the shows I was planning to
事实，简，大卫和康妮。所以她写道，我的两个问题是，那是帕姆看的电视节目列表吗？我的第二个问题是康妮是谁？所以我看了这些。这些都是我的笔迹。我不知道。我不知道康妮是谁。我显然只是把它扔在那里作为一点，我不知道，调味品。伙计们，那是我计划
watch that night. That's just a note to myself. Apparently, I remember being very much into Big Brother and I guess I really wanted to make sure I didn't forget to watch this Animal Planet special on Jane Goodall. And then if I had time, I was going to watch some 48 hours. But you guys, just to know, Jenna, she, of course, would write that down and write down the time and everything. It wouldn't just be like, oh, I think I'm going to check this out tonight. I will make a schedule of my evening. Here will be my viewing schedule for tonight.
那天晚上看的节目列表。那只是给自己的笔记。显然，我记得非常喜欢《老大哥》，我想我真的很想确保我没忘记看这个关于珍·古道尔的动物星球特别节目。然后如果我有时间，我会看一些《48小时》。但伙计们，要知道，珍娜，她当然会把它写下来，写下时间和一切。不会只是像，哦，我想我今晚要看看这个。我会制定我的晚间计划。这就是我今晚的观看计划。
Well, I think this just tells you everything you need to know about me. I want a little trash TV. Yeah. I love animals. And then I do like a good mystery. Yeah. It really does say everything you need to know about you. I think that's a great night of TV personally. All right, lady. Well, why don't we take a break here?
嗯，我觉得这说明了关于我的一切。我想要一点垃圾电视。是的。我喜欢动物。然后我确实喜欢好的悬疑片。是的，它确实说明了关于你的一切。我觉得那是一个很棒的电视之夜。好吧，女士。那我们为什么不在这里休息一下呢？
And when we come back, let's join Michael and Jim at the buffet. Oh, let's join them at the buffet. You know, I love a buffet. We need a sting for that. Craving an escape? Bring the vibrant flavors of Mexican street eat energy to life in your kitchen with Tia Rosa Tortillas. Born in Mexico, Tia Rosa knows how to turn your next taco night at home into the real deal.
当我们回来时，让我们加入迈克尔和吉姆在自助餐的行列。哦，让我们加入他们的自助餐。你知道，我喜欢自助餐。我们需要一个音效。渴望逃离？用Tia Rosa玉米饼在你的厨房里让墨西哥街头美食的活力风味变得生动起来。诞生于墨西哥，Tia Rosa知道如何让你家里的下一个塔可之夜变得地道。
Find Tia Rosa Tortillas at select grocery stores and get the good vibes going. Tia Rosa, Tia Rosa. Tia Rosa. From commutes that become learning sessions to dishwashing filled with laughs, podcasts can help you make the most out of your everyday. And when it comes to everyday spending,
在精选杂货店找到Tia Rosa玉米饼，让好心情开始吧。Tia Rosa，Tia Rosa。Tia Rosa。从变成学习课程的通勤到充满笑声的洗碗，播客可以帮助你充分利用你的每一天。当谈到日常消费时，
you can count on the PC Insiders World Elite Mastercard to help you earn the most PC optimum points everywhere you shop. The PC Insiders World Elite Mastercard to help you earn the most PC Optimum points everywhere you shop. The PC Insider's World Elite Mastercard, the card for living unlimited. Conditions apply to all benefits. Visit PCFinancial.ca for details. Spring is here and you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost?
您可以信赖 PC Insiders World Elite 万事达卡，它能帮您在购物时赚取最多的 PC Optimum 积分。PC Insiders World Elite 万事达卡能帮您在购物时赚取最多的 PC Optimum 积分。PC Insiders World Elite 万事达卡，一张让您生活无极限的卡片。所有福利均受条款约束。详情请访问 PCFinancial.ca。春天到了，现在您几乎可以通过 Uber Eats 订购任何所需物品。我们所说的“几乎”是什么意思呢？
You can't get a well-groomed lawn delivered, but you can get chicken parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now. Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. Alright, we are back. Jen, I have a question for you. Okay. Who left the ham out?
您无法通过外送获得修剪整齐的草坪，但可以获得鸡肉帕尔马干酪。阳光？不行。葡萄酒？可以。通过 Uber Eats 订购几乎、几乎任何东西。立即下单。酒精饮料仅限特定市场。详情请查看应用程序。好了，我们回来了。Jen，我有个问题要问你。好的。是谁把火腿放在外面的？
What? And why would you want a sandwich when you went to bed? Huh, Elle MacPherson? huh? what are you talking about right now? i'm gonna keep going i'm gonna wait to see when you get it. oh, leaving the ham out for the bear was a joke? oh, it's his birthday? oh, surprise! what a bunch of assholes! are you with me yet? no, elmick fearson left a ham out? elmick fearson is in bed and says, you know, I'd really like a sandwich. And then- Oh my- wait! No you did not.
什么？你睡觉的时候为什么要吃三明治？哈，Elle MacPherson？哈？你现在在说什么？我要继续说下去，我要看看你什么时候能听懂。哦，把火腿留给熊是个笑话？哦，那是他的生日？哦，惊喜！真是一群混蛋！你跟上我的节奏了吗？没有，Elmick Fearson 把火腿放在外面了？Elmick Fearson 在床上说，你知道吗，我真的很想吃个三明治。然后——哦，我的天——等等！你才没有。
I watched The Edge! You didn't! Oh, I could cry! What did you think? I watched The Edge. These were my comments right out of the gate. Okay. Right away as I start watching the movie.
我看了《势不两立》（The Edge）！你没看！哦，我都要哭了！你觉得怎么样？我看了《势不两立》。这些是我刚开始看时的评论。好的。我刚开始看这部电影时就立刻说了。
I'm not getting on that plane. Who's getting on that plane? What do you mean? Getting- That did not look safe already. Already. I'm anxious, movie. I'm not getting on that plane. Who's getting on that plane? What do you mean? Getting, that did not look safe already. Already I'm anxious, Jenna. They're on this plane and now they're going to the middle of nowhere.
我才不上那架飞机。谁要上那架飞机？你什么意思？上——那看起来一点也不安全。已经不安全了。我很焦虑，电影。我才不上那架飞机。谁要上那架飞机？你什么意思？上，那看起来一点也不安全。我已经很焦虑了，Jenna。他们在那架飞机上，现在他们要去荒郊野外。
And then they say, don't leave food out. Then he's got to get up and make her a sandwich. And she left a, someone left a ham out and there's a bear. And then they're like, surprise. And I'm like, they scared the crap out of me of me and then I said what a bunch of dicks. Those aren't good friends. I know the quote you love is what one man can do. What one man has done another can do. Do you know the one I love from this movie? What is it? There goes a guy with a plane. I have to say I don't remember that. Come on. Robert says that a lot. And then
然后他们说，不要把食物放在外面。然后他得起床给她做三明治。然后她留下了一个，有人把火腿放在外面，结果有只熊。然后他们就像，惊喜。我就想，他们把我吓坏了，然后我说真是一群混蛋。那些不是好朋友。我知道你喜欢的那句台词是“一个人能做到的事，另一个人也能做到”。你知道我从这部电影里最喜欢哪一句吗？是什么？那儿走过一个带着飞机的人。我得说我不记得那句了。拜托。Robert 经常说那句。然后
what did Elle MacPherson, what did her character have like edged on his watch for all the nights? Okay, listen, you didn't love the mental fortitude and gymnastics that it took for these two people who are kind of at odds to have to work together to survive the wilderness and a bear that was actively hunting them. Tracking them. Okay, I like the part when Anthony Hopkins, his character Charles, as you know, cause Alec Baldwin who plays Robert
Elle MacPherson，她的角色在手表上刻了什么，为了那些夜晚？好吧，听着，你不喜欢这两个原本不和的人为了在荒野中生存并躲避一只主动捕猎他们的熊而不得不共同努力所展现出的心理韧性和灵活性吗？追踪他们。好吧，我喜欢 Anthony Hopkins 饰演的 Charles 的部分，如你所知，因为饰演 Robert 的 Alec Baldwin
will say Charles 300 times. Yeah. When Charles is like, repeat after me, this bear is not going to kill us. The bear is not going to kill us. Yes. It's so good. It's so good. Angela, this is written by David Mamet, one of the all-time great American playwrights. I got that. It's a masterful work. I got it. I got it. I think it would be maybe better on the stage is what I'm going to say. How do you do this on the stage? I don't know. You have a person in a bear costume? I don't know. It's just the way his cadence is. Charles, Charles, Charles. Anywhere. I about pooped myself when several times in this movie. It was so stressful.
会说 300 次 Charles。是的。当 Charles 说，跟我重复一遍，这只熊不会杀了我们。这只熊不会杀了我们。是的。太棒了。太棒了。Angela，这是 David Mamet 写的，他是史上最伟大的美国剧作家之一。我知道。这是一部杰作。我知道了。我知道了。我觉得它在舞台上可能会更好，我是这么想的。你怎么在舞台上表演这个？我不知道。你找个人穿上熊的戏服？我不知道。只是他的语调就是那样。Charles，Charles，Charles。无论如何。我在电影里好几次差点吓尿了。太紧张了。
But you loved it. You loved the movie though, right? I didn't love it. I didn't love it. But I watched it for you. I don't ever need to watch it again. Also, they did so many stupid things. Like they would finally get a gun they could shoot the bear with and then one of them would like throw it in the pit or like get the bullets out of it. Or they would, they were just like, none of those, none of these things that you're saying happened at the end. At the end. I don't want to ruin it if anyone hasn't seen it.
但你很喜欢它。你很喜欢这部电影，对吧？我不喜欢。我不喜欢。但我为了你看了。我再也不需要看它了。而且，他们做了很多愚蠢的事情。比如他们终于拿到了一把可以射杀熊的枪，然后其中一个人竟然把它扔进了坑里，或者把子弹取了出来。或者他们，他们只是，你说的这些事情在结尾都没有发生。在结尾。如果有人还没看过，我不想剧透。
And I know we're going off on a long tangent. The bear is already dead at that point, Angela. Yeah. But now there's a man pointing a gun at you. And then when he falls in the pit, you're like, I don't need the gun. And then he's just gonna keep trying to kill you, buddy. Okay?
我知道我们扯远了。Angela，那只熊在那时已经死了。是的。但现在有个男人用枪指着你。然后当他掉进坑里时，你会想，我不需要枪了。然后他还是会一直试图杀了你，伙计。好吗？
So anyway, okay. I don't know what to say. Anyway, listen, here's the thing. I watched it for you because you're my BFF. I now get it, I get it. I'm fascinated that this is a movie that you choose to watch every year. It makes me really fascinated by you. I've always thought you were an interesting person. You're even more complex to me now. I might have to rewatch it one more time with you so I can trash talk it.
所以，总之，好吧。我不知道该说什么。总之，听着，事情是这样的。我为了你看了它，因为你是我的好闺蜜。我现在明白了，我明白了。我很着迷于这竟然是你每年都会选择看的电影。这让我对你感到非常着迷。我一直觉得你是个有趣的人。现在你对我来说更复杂了。我可能得和你再看一遍，这样我才能吐槽它。
And if you want to do the same with me, if you want to pick a Game of Thrones episode and trash talk it with me, that's fine. You know, I wouldn't do that to you. Yes, you would do that to you because you love it. And I wouldn't do I wouldn't trash talk something that you love. You would maybe I just don't think I would. I think you would make some grunting noises and I rolls. There'd be something. No, I would just I would just mock you to others behind your back. Vicious. I'm kidding. You know, Angela, sweetheart, you know, I would mock you to your face.
如果你想和我做同样的事，如果你想选一集《权力的游戏》和我一起吐槽，那没问题。你知道，我不会那样对你的。是的，你会那样对你，因为你喜欢它。而我不会——我不会吐槽你喜欢的东西。你会的，也许吧。我只是觉得我不会。我觉得你会发出一些咕哝声和翻白眼。总会有的。不，我只会背地里向别人嘲笑你。恶毒。开玩笑的。你知道，Angela，亲爱的，你知道，我会当面嘲笑你的。
So that's the kind of friendship we have. Sweetheart. I was trying to figure out how to bring up the edge to you and that I had watched it. I watched it three weeks ago and I've been trying to figure out where to bring it up. And then when all of a sudden Michael was at the buffet, I was like, buffet, ham, here's my end. I'm going to say who left the ham out. She'll get it right away. But it's so random.
这就是我们的友谊。亲爱的。我一直在想怎么向你提起《势不两立》以及我已经看过它了。我三周前看了它，我一直在想该在哪里提起。然后当 Michael 突然出现在自助餐台时，我就想，自助餐、火腿，这就是我的切入点。我要说“是谁把火腿放在外面的”。她马上就会明白的。但这太随机了。
I get it. It's so random. Anyway, lady, I watched the edge for you. I think we're even for a bit. You watched one 90 minute movie. I watched three seasons of a television show. Okay, maybe. Okay, fine. Okay, I'm gonna start Fleabag. Okay. Okay. Yes. Okay. Watch fleabag. Okay. Anyway, so we'll episode. Back to the episode. Jim, he is desperately wanting to ask Michael about Pam. Yeah. But he just can't even bring himself to ask about her.
我明白了。这太随机了。总之，女士，我为了你看了《势不两立》。我觉得我们扯平了。你看了一部 90 分钟的电影。我看了三季电视剧。好吧，也许吧。好吧，行。好吧，我要开始看《伦敦生活》（Fleabag）了。好的。好的。是的。好的。看《伦敦生活》。总之，回到剧集。Jim，他非常想问 Michael 关于 Pam 的事。是的。但他就是无法开口问她。
No, he asked about Toby. Yeah, and Michael's like, Toby is everything that's wrong with the paper business. Is that why you left? And all of a sudden, Jenna, it all becomes clear to you that this whole time, Michael really took it personally that Jim left. And he's been trying to figure out why he thought it was because of him. And he he needs to know why Jim left his friend. Why would he leave me? Yeah. And then there's there's one there's a little couple of lines here
不，他问了 Toby。是的，Michael 说，Toby 是造纸行业一切问题的根源。这就是你离开的原因吗？突然间，Jenna，你终于明白，一直以来，Michael 真的觉得 Jim 的离开是针对他个人的。他一直在想为什么，他以为是因为他。他需要知道 Jim 为什么要离开他的朋友。他为什么要离开我？是的。然后这里有几句台词
that made me laugh so hard. Jim, they're talking about Ryan, and Jim says, tell him I said hi. And Michael, with all seriousness, says I will call him later with that message. And I just picture, I just picture that Michael just keeps calling Ryan. Yes, yes. And then they all start to sit down to eat lunch, and Michael, he just wants to impress everyone.
让我笑得好厉害。Jim，他们在谈论 Ryan，Jim 说，替我向他问好。Michael 非常严肃地说，我稍后会打电话告诉他这个消息。我脑海中浮现出 Michael 一直在给 Ryan 打电话的画面。是的，是的。然后他们都坐下来吃午饭，Michael，他只是想给每个人留下深刻印象。
He whips out that $100 bill per DM is like, here's the tip. Yes. And the busboy is so excited. The busboy is like, that's amazing, right? Yes. And Jan is not impressed though, because she's just sort of like, you know, Michael, we're here for work. We're going to be in and out of meetings all day. You seem to think this is a party. So there's a little bit of tension for work. We're going to of meetings all day. You as a party. So there's a here. I have a fun fact.
他掏出那张 100 美元的钞票作为小费，说，这是小费。是的。服务生非常兴奋。服务生心想，那太棒了，对吧？是的。但 Jan 并不买账，因为她就像是，你知道，Michael，我们是来工作的。我们整天都要开会。你似乎觉得这是个派对。所以这里有一点紧张气氛。我们整天都要开会。你觉得这是个派对。所以这里有一点。我有个有趣的事实。
out that $100 bill that m I looked it up. That would and three cents. Oh Jenna to know the value of $100 bill then and now. I just wanted to know. I'm going to have to. And I could have let it go. I could have kept it to myself. You could have, but you couldn't. But I couldn't. You couldn't. So there it is. There it is. Well, then Jan says, I can't stay on top of you 24 seven and Michael has a small nose bleed looking at camera. So desperately wants to say that's what she said.
掏出那张 100 美元的钞票，我查了一下。那相当于三美分。哦，Jenna，了解 100 美元钞票在当时和现在的价值。我只是想知道。我本可以放过它的。我本可以把它藏在心里的。你本可以的，但你没做到。但我做不到。你做不到。所以就是这样。就是这样。好吧，然后 Jan 说，我不能 24 小时盯着你，Michael 看着镜头流了一点鼻血。他非常想说“那是她说的”（That's what she said）。
But then Angela scandal. Who's in the big sunglasses walking up. What is with your character having all of these like weird incognito disguised hats and glasses in her closet. You're hilarious. You draw more attention to yourself than not. She's got a closet of hats and wigs and glasses. She's like on The Americans. Yes. She's got her rendezvous. And she's like, and of course, why did they use Jane Doe? That's so creepy. Do you have a key for Jane Doe?
但然后 Angela 丑闻。戴着大墨镜走过来的是谁？你的角色衣柜里为什么会有这么多奇怪的隐身伪装帽和眼镜？你太搞笑了。你反而更引人注目了。她有一柜子的帽子、假发和眼镜。她就像在演《美国谍梦》（The Americans）一样。是的。她有她的秘密约会。她说，当然，他们为什么要用 Jane Doe？太诡异了。你有 Jane Doe 的钥匙吗？
She narrowly avoids Michael. But she gets her key. She's checking in. Oh, oh, Jenna, we have to talk about, this is the one moment in the whole episode that Jim and Pam hear each other. Jim and Pam, it's as close as they'll get to being together. And it's when Pam calls Michael and Jim overhears.
她险些避开了 Michael。但她拿到了钥匙。她在办理入住。哦，哦，Jenna，我们必须谈谈，这是整集中 Jim 和 Pam 听到对方声音的唯一时刻。Jim 和 Pam，这是他们最接近在一起的时刻。那是 Pam 给 Michael 打电话，Jim 无意中听到了。
And he's like, hey, I'm with Jim and Dwight and Josh say hi. And Pam's like, hi. And that's it. That's their only moment. But not only that, this is a layered moment. Because in this moment, not only did they hear each other's voices, but in this moment, Jim knows that now that Pam is single and Pam now knows that Jim knows because
他说，嘿，我和 Jim、Dwight 和 Josh 在一起，向他们问好。Pam 说，嗨。就这样。那是他们唯一的时刻。但不仅如此，这是一个多层次的时刻。因为在这一刻，他们不仅听到了彼此的声音，而且在这一刻，Jim 知道 Pam 现在单身了，而 Pam 也知道 Jim 知道了，因为
Michael wishes her good luck on your first date yeah so Pam Pam knows Jim knows I'm single you know she was hoping he would find out somehow yeah now he knows he doesn't know he knows he doesn't know. He knows he does not call. He doesn't call him either. Why aren't they calling each other? I don't know. It's like the age other. It's like the age of innocence. I guess that book made me crazy. I'm like, just be together already.
Michael 祝她第一次约会好运，是的，所以 Pam 知道 Jim 知道我单身了，你知道她曾希望他能以某种方式发现，是的，现在他知道了，他不知道他知道，他知道他不知道。他知道他没有打电话。他也没有给她打电话。他们为什么不给对方打电话？我不知道。这就像《纯真年代》（The Age of Innocence）。我想那本书让我疯了。我就想，快在一起吧。
All right. Well, then Michael has a talking head where he's kind of going off on Jim. He says Jim and I, we have different definitions of friendship. on Jim. He says Jim and I, we have different definitions of friendship. Apparently, Jim thinks friendship is moving to Stanford. So he's not going to talk to Jim anymore. He's had enough jilted lover.
好吧，然后 Michael 有一个采访片段，他在那里抱怨 Jim。他说 Jim 和我，我们对友谊的定义不同。显然，Jim 认为友谊就是搬到斯坦福。所以他不再和 Jim 说话了。他受够了，像个被抛弃的情人。
He is so heartbroken. He is Angela. We had a really great fan catch. You'll like it. It's from Claudia Cano. She said there is a rubber ducky in two shots. There's one at 14 minutes 56 seconds, which is in the background of this talking head. And then again at 19 minutes 47 seconds. Did Michael travel with the rubber ducky or get it on the duck's belly you can't see it it probably says a paper company name like for sure we're not quacking around we're number one in
他太心碎了。Angela，我们有一个非常棒的粉丝发现。你会喜欢的。来自 Claudia Cano。她说有两个镜头里有一只橡皮鸭。一个在 14 分 56 秒，在采访片段的背景里。然后又在 19 分 47 秒出现。Michael 是带着橡皮鸭旅行，还是在鸭子的肚皮上，你看不到，上面可能写着纸业公司的名字，比如我们绝对不是在胡闹，我们是第一名
colored paper exactly the duck stops here angela you are really good at these. Give me more. If you think of more, shout them out. No, I won't. Okay. Well, my favorite part of this talking head, Angela, is that we widened to reveal that Michael is actually having a drink with the hammer mill rep. I know. It is just- The whole talking head has been delivered with another person in the room. I don't- I have a fun fact about the hammer mill rep. Okay. That was played by actor Matt Price. Angela, Matt Price screen tested for the role of Dwight. What? No. I screen tested with him. He was one of the people that I was
彩色纸，没错，鸭子到此为止，Angela，你真的很擅长这些。再给我多一点。如果你想到更多，大声说出来。不，我不会。好吧，好吧，我最喜欢这个采访片段的部分是，镜头拉远，显示 Michael 实际上正在和 Hammermill 的代表喝酒。我知道。这简直是——整个采访片段都是在房间里有另一个人的情况下完成的。我不知道——关于 Hammermill 的代表，我有一个有趣的事实。好的。那是演员 Matt Price 扮演的。Angela，Matt Price 试镜过 Dwight 的角色。什么？不。我和他一起试镜过。他是我在最终试镜时被分到一组的人之一。天哪。他们很喜欢他，Greg 想找个办法让他回来。顺便说一句，随着剧集的推进，很多参加过主要角色最终试镜的人都被带回来作为客串明星，因为 Greg 太喜欢他们了。我喜欢 Greg 的这一点。我知道他不会忘记人。他不会。如果你让他印象深刻，他会为你找到位置。好吧，在 15 分 42 秒，Jim 现在要捉弄 Dwight 了。就像过去一样，对吧？他拿到了他房间的钥匙，他要进去做点什么。好吧，关于这一天我有一些故事。是的，因为当他打开门时发生了什么？Angela，Jim 发现了什么？床上躺着一位女士。
paired with at the final audition. Oh my god. They loved him and Greg wanted a way to bring him back. And by the way, as we go through the series, a lot of the people who had final screen tests for main roles are brought back as guest stars throughout the show because Greg just loved them so much. I love that about Greg. I know he doesn't forget people. He does. If you impress him, he'll find a place for you. Alright, so at 15 minutes 42 seconds, Jim is now going to prank Dwight. It's like old times, right? He got a key to his room and he is going to go in there and do something. All right, I have some stories about this day. Yes, because what happens when he opens the door? Angela, what is Jim find? He lady on the bed.
他发现了一个他以为是妓女的人，但实际上是 Angela。好吧，好吧，来自 Earl 的 Angela 粉丝提问。我们在 Dwight 的酒店房间里看到的真的是你的腿吗？是的，真的是我的腿，当然他们为我挑选了一整套服装。我必须去试装，尽管你其实看不到太多。它很保守，抱歉让你失望了，但那是一件粉色的睡衣上衣，长袖，然后我穿了这种黑色波点裤子，就像睡裤，但它们有点绸缎质感。
He finds someone who he thinks is a hooker, but it's actually Angela. All right. Well, Angela fan question from I've Earl Angela. Is that really your leg that we see in Dwight's hotel room? Yes, it's really my leg and of course they had a whole outfit picked out for me. I had to have a wardrobe fitting for it even though you don't really see much. It was conservative, sorry to disappoint, but it was a pink pajama top, long sleeve and then I have these black polka dot pants like pajama pants but they were kind of satiny.
这些黑色波点裤子，就像睡裤，但它们有点绸缎质感。哦，那是，那是性感的部分。是的。所以当你抬起腿时可以看到我的小腿，我把脚趾甲涂成了红色。所以就是这样，但我曾在一次采访中谈到过这个场景，因为我从来没有和 Jim 的对手戏。如果你看完整部剧，Jim 和 Angela 很少互动。是的。所以 John 和我在现实生活中是朋友，我们当时很兴奋。我们终于能一起演戏了，你们没看到的是，当他打开门时，墙上有一面镜子
these black polka dot pants like pajama pants, but they were kind of satiny. Oh, that's, that's the sexy part. Yes. And so you could see Mike, you could see my calf when I raised my leg and I had painted my toenails red. So there's that, but I had talked about this scene in an interview because I don't ever get any scenes with Jim. Jim and Angela rarely interact if you watch the whole show. Yeah. So John and I as friends in real life we were giddy. We were so excited to finally be in the scene together and what you guys didn't see was when he opens the door there's a
墙上有一面镜子，他看到了我的腿，他吓坏了，但我能在镜子里看到他所有的表情。我能看到一切。当他看到我的腿时，他的脸，每次 John 演这个场景，他都会做出那种从惊恐到震惊的反应。太搞笑了。
mirror on the wall and he sees my legs and he freaks out, but I could see his whole expression in the mirror. I could see everything. And his face when he saw my legs, every time John did the scene, he would do this range of reaction of like horror and just like shock. And it was so funny.
我们笑得太厉害了，尽量不毁掉拍摄。当然，我的角色就像是“D”，他们还在争论他们能看到我多少。只看到我的腿，才能真正卖力。就像 Jim 到底看到了我多少，对吧？所以我们稍微玩了一下。然后 Jenna，我觉得这是我的角色第一次叫 Dwight “D”，我们确立了这个昵称。我想是的。是的。
We were laughing so hard, trying not to ruin the takes. And then of course my character's like D and they were debating on how much of me they were gonna see. Just my legs, to really sell it. Like how much did Jim see of me, right? So we sort of played around with that a little bit. And then Jenna, I think this is the first time my character calls Dwight D and we established that nickname. I think it is. Yeah
是的，我不知道。我们会追踪的，伙计们。我们会追踪的，但我没有追踪我第一次叫他 D 的时间，Angela。我觉得我们现在得和 Ryan、Kelly、Pam 和 Alan 进行一次双重约会。太尴尬了，Jenna。太糟糕了。这个场景看的时候太尴尬了。是的，Kelly 强行喂 Ryan 吃了一些蘸番茄酱的薯条。
Yeah, I don't know. We'll track it guys. We'll track it, but I don't track the first time I call him D Angela. I think we need to go on a double date now with Ryan Kelly Pam and Alan So cringy, Jenna. So awful. This scene was so awkward to watch. Yes, Kelly is force feeding Ryan some french fries with ketchup.
她坚持说他喜欢。他喜欢番茄酱。他喜欢。然后 Alan，我的意思是，Alan 只是有点俗气，Jenna。他只是有点，哦天哪。呃。是的。好吧，Robert 告诉我，他最喜欢的 Alan 台词是，人们总是说，不要太前卫，但我不知道还有什么其他方式。
She insists that he loves it. He loves ketchup. He loves it. And then Alan, I mean, Alan is just kind of cheesy, Jenna. He's just a little, Oh my gosh. Ugh. Yes. Well, Robert told me that his favorite Alan line is, people always say, don't be edgy, but I don't know any other way.
他说，这太做作了。他说这是非常棒的喜剧写作。他还告诉我，他至今仍被认作是“自由薯条男”（freedom fries guy）。他非常感激。人们真的叫他“自由薯条男”吗？自由薯条男。嘿，你是《办公室》里的那个自由薯条男。他还告诉我一个非常甜蜜的故事。他说在我们拍摄结束后，Mindy 陪他走出去，一直不停地说她有多感激他能来参加演出。
He was like, it was so pretentious. It said it was such great comic writing. He also told me that he still gets recognized as the freedom fries guy. And he is very grateful. Do people call him the freedom fries guy? Freedom fries guy. Hey, you're the freedom fries guy from the office. And he also told me this really sweet story. He said after we were done shooting, Mindy walked him out and just went on and on about how grateful she was to him for
然后她告诉他，当 Allison 在给人们录像时，因为她就是这么做的。Allison 会为角色举行试镜并录像。他们有一个想法，他们可能想在这个角色中启用一名 SNL（周六夜现场）的演员。
being on the show. And then she told him that while Allison was putting people on tape, cause that's what she would do. Allison would hold auditions for parts and put people on tape. They had this idea that they might wanna cast an SNL cast member in this role.
我不会说是谁，但 Mindy 说我们看了 Allison 发来的录像带，你太搞笑了，以至于我们最终把这个角色给了你，而不是提供给那个 SNL 的演员，Robert 说直到今天。他把这当作一种荣誉勋章。
And I'm not gonna say who, but Mindy said we watched the tapes that Allison sent over and you were so funny that we ended up giving you the role instead of offering it to this SNL cast member and Robert said it is still to this day. He wears that as like a badge
荣誉勋章。是的，他说。我可以吹嘘我击败了一名 SNL 演员进入了《办公室》。所以他只是，他太谦虚了，太感激能谈论这件事了。太棒了。好吧，好吧，与这 37 秒交叉。Michael 去他的派对，但没人留下来，因为那里没人，他觉得很尴尬，但扮演者是 Steve Little，我注意到了，我喜欢 Steve Little，你们知道他在我 Netflix 的剧集《Haters Back Off》中扮演 Uncle Jim，它是基于 Miranda Sings，基于 Colleen Ballinger 和 Eric Stockland 以及 Francesca Riale 的那个角色，Steve Little 和我可能有一段最尴尬的恋情，甚至比 Dwight 和 Angela 更尴尬，伙计们。我的意思是我们在浴缸里约会。不，我甚至。你以为恋情不会比 Dwight 和 Angela 更奇怪，直到你看了《Haters Back Off》看到你和 Steve Little，绝对 100%，那个男人读电话簿我都会笑死。我会笑得很大声。他可以。他太搞笑了。他嘴里说出的每一句话都让我发笑，我们一起即兴发挥了很多，真正创造了这种诡异的关系，而且，嗯，我只是，我只是爱他。
badge of honor. Yeah, he was like. I can brag that I beat out an SNL cast me the office. So he just, h so humble and so grateful to talk about this. Such great. All right. Well, s criss crossing with these 37 seconds. Jenna Michael to his party who doesn't stick
我是 Steve Little 的超级超级粉丝。好吧，我和他在《Haters Back Off》中合作过，但很多人也从《体育老师笑传》（Eastbound and Down）以及其他许多作品中认识他。他真是一位非常棒的喜剧演员。好吧，所以，你知道，Pam 的约会进行得并不顺利。她说，Alan 有点无聊，对吧？是的。她说那不是一段爱情连接。她说她再次喜欢上某人时就会知道。
around because no one's there and he's like awkward but it's played by Steve Little I noticed I love Steve Little you guys know he played Uncle Jim in the show I did on Netflix called Haters Back Off it's it's based off Miranda Sings based off that character with Colleen Ballinger and Eric Stockland and Francesca Riale and Steve Little and I have maybe one of the most awkward romances even more awkward than Dwight and Angela you guys. I mean we have a date in a bathtub. No, I don't even. You think that a romance can't get weirder than Dwight and Angela until you watch haters back off and see you and Steve little for sure 100% that man could read the phone book and I'd be cracking up. I'd be laughing so hard. He can. He is so funny. Just everything that comes out of his mouth made me laugh and we got to improvise a lot together and really create this creepy relationship and And, um, I just, I just love him.
因为她已经喜欢那个人了。她确实喜欢。然后 Jim 走出电梯，发现 Michael 独自在房间里，开着频闪灯和一些舞曲，音乐很大声，像很大声。我不敢相信没人打电话投诉他。音乐太大了。我知道我像个 100 岁的老人，但我当时想，那太吵了。好吧，Michael 真的很暴躁。我们很少看到 Michael 这样。他表现得很被动攻击。
I am a huge, huge Steve little fan. Well, I worked with him on haters back off, but a lot of people knew him from eastbound and down as well as many other things. He's just a really great comedic actor. Well, so, you know, Pam's date did not go great. She says, Alan was a bit of a dead, right? Yeah. It was not a love connection, she says. She says she'll know it when she likes someone again.
这是 Michael 的傲慢。这是 Michael 的傲慢。这是 Michael 的傲慢，但我有一点背景故事，伙计们。如果你看删除的场景，还记得我们说有一些 Dwight 和 Angela 的内容被剪掉了吗？是的。所以你实际上看到 Dwight 在看手表。
Because she already likes that person. She does. Then Jim gets off the elevator and discovers Michael is alone in his room with a strobe light and some some dance music, loud music, like loud. I couldn't believe no one called and complained on him. The music was so loud. I know I'm 100, but I was like, that's very loud. Well, Michael is really grouchy. We don't see Michael like this a lot. He's being passive aggressive.
他得去房间找 Angela，他编了一个蹩脚的借口，把 Michael 一个人留在酒店房间里。Michael 对此很生气。他生气是因为他觉得 Jim 为了 Josh Porter 把他抛弃了。所以这里发生了很多事。Michael 觉得他的朋友们抛弃了他。
It's Michael Sass. It's Michael Sass. It's Michael Sass, but I have a little bit of backstory guys. If you watch the deleted scenes, remember how we said there's some of the Dwight Angela stuff that plays out that got cut? Yeah. So you actually see Dwight is checking his watch.
这也是 Jim 终于告诉 Michael 的地方，我离开不是因为你，Michael。你是个好老板。我离开是因为 Pam，Michael 就像你真的离开了。这太疯狂了，因为 Pam 现在单身了，你觉得你可以回来。好吧，我也觉得，我觉得他想让 Jim 知道这一点，但他同时也立刻感到释然。是的，不是因为他，而且他的朋友还是他的朋友。
He's got to get to Angela in the room and he makes up a lame excuse and he leaves Michael alone in his hotel room. And Michael's grumpy about that. He's grumpy because he feels like Jim has ditched him for Josh Porter. So there's a lot happening here. Michael feels kind of like his friends have abandoned him.
是的。而 Jim，Jim 再次与 Michael 分享了一些极其私人的事情。我知道，因为 Jim 说，听着，伙计，我为 Pam 孤注一掷了两次，结果被拒绝了两次。我只是，我不会，我不会给她打电话。我不知道，我觉得他有道理。就像他明确表达了自己的感受。他在办公室里吻了她。她知道他的感受。他说我爱你。是的，他说我爱你。
This is also where Jim finally tells Michael, I did not leave because of you, Michael. You were a great boss. I left not leave because of you Michael. You were a great boss. I left because of Pam and Michael is kind of like you did. That's crazy because Pam single now you you think you can come back. Well, I also think I think he wants Jim to know that but he's also instantly relieved. Yes, that it wasn't because of him and that his friend is still his friend.
球在她那边。百分之百。我完全理解他为什么会觉得如果她取消了婚礼而没有给我打电话。我该怎么办？我要去说，嘿，你取消婚礼了吗？现在我可以有机会了吗？Michael 告诉他们他和 Jim 是最好的朋友。最好的朋友。所以这对 Michael 来说最终是一个胜利，因为他找回了他的朋友。他做成了一笔像 Hammermill 那样的大生意，对吧？Jan 最终对 Michael 作为销售员的表现印象深刻。他不是 Josh Porter 之后的第二名。不。所以 Michael 在这里有一个不错的结局。他确实有。
Yes. And Jim, Jim once again is sharing something incredibly personal with Michael. I know because Jim says, listen, man, I put it on the line for Pam twice and I got rejected twice. I'm just, I'm not going to, I'm not going to call her. I don I don't know like and I think he has a good point. Like he made his feelings clear. He smooched her in the office. She knows how he feels. He said I love you. Yeah, he said I love you.
他在这次大会上经历了很多，但最终他赢了。我们在这一集的结尾有一个非常有趣的彩蛋。Michael 和 Dwight 在酒店房间里。他们关掉灯，因为他们要打开黑光灯。因为这是个派对。我想他们有个派对。是的。是的。房间里到处都是这些飞溅物。
The ball is in her court. A hundred percent. I totally get how he's like if she called off the wedding and she didn't phone me. What am I supposed to do with that? I'm gonna go be like, hey, did you call off the wedding now? Can I have a chance? Michael tells them that he and Jim are best friends. Best friends. So it ends up being a win for Michael because he gets his friend back. He makes a huge like sale with Hammer Mill, right? Jan ultimately is impressed with Michael as a salesman. He's not number two behind Josh Porter. No. So Michael has a nice ending here. He does.
Dwight 说，好吧，要么是血，要么是尿，要么是精液。我喜欢 Michael 的生活。他说，天哪，我希望是尿。我希望是尿。你什么时候会希望是尿？我想在那种情况下。这真是一集非常有趣的剧集。我做这一集玩得很开心。重温它真是太有趣了。我只记得笑了
He goes through a lot at this convention, but in the end he wins. And we've got a very funny tag at the end of this episode. Michael and Dwight are in the hotel room. They turn off the lights because they're going to turn on a black light. Because it's a party. I guess they have a party. Yeah. Yes. And there are just these splatters all over the room.
很多，这对本周的我来说是一种真正的快乐。希望你们喜欢。我想向 Kent Subornak 的 Kentopedia 事实表示巨大的感谢，也要感谢 Robert Bagnell 的所有有趣故事。你可以在他的 Instagram 上关注 Robert Bagnell。就像是 i bags to gram，或者你可以 f 他有这个很棒的 tra bags。他花了像 l
And Dwight says, well, it's either blood, urine, or semen. And I love Michael's life. He says, god, I hope it's urine. I hope it's urine. When do you ever hope it's urine? I think in that situation. This was a really fun episode. I had such a great time doing it. It was so fun to re-watch it again. I just remember laughing
大部分时间都在东南亚旅行，记录他的旅行，并将它们制作成这些非常可看、有趣、非常令人上瘾的视频。我强烈推荐。总之，非常感谢那些家伙，我们下周见，讨论《政变》（The Coup）。哦。
a lot and that was a real joy for me this week. I hope you guys enjoyed it. I want to give a big shout out and a big thanks to Kent Subornak for his Kentopedia facts and also to Robert Begnell for all his fun stories. You Robert Bagnell on his Inst bags to gram. It's like i bags to gram or you can f He's got this amazing tra bags. He spent like the l
感谢收听 Office Ladies' Second Drink。本集最初是与 Earwulf 合作创作的。Office Ladies 是 Odyssey 的节目，由 Jenna Fischer 和 Angela Kinsey 制作。我们的执行制片人是 Cassie Jerkins，音频工程师和副制片人是 Daniella Silva。Odyssey 的执行制片人是 Jenna Weiss-Berman 和 Leah Reese Dennis。Office Ladies 由 Chris Basil 混音和母带处理。
mostly through Southeast been documenting his trav them into these very watchable, fun, very addictive videos. I highly recommend. Anyway, big thanks to those guys, and we'll see you next week for The Coup. Ooh.
我们的主题曲是 Creed Bratton 的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil.
感谢您收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师兼助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔进行混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演唱的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。